bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle journée la dernière de cette
semaine 3 de la processeig et je suis
rejoint par j'allais dire le meilleur
joueur breton de tous les temps et non
c'est le meilleur pêcheur breton de tous
les temps enfin selon lui en tout cas
comment ça va mon petit Kevin
c'est possible que j'ai fait une
boulette je crois je sais pas
attends je me suis mis en non non le
début du stream aléatoire dites-nous
dans le chat si vous si vous l'entendez
ou pas
donc ce que je vais faire c'est que je
vais changer le c'est une chance sur
deux à chaque fois je suis pas habitué
c'est nouveau écouteurs tu sais
et là voilà on tente enfin on t'entendre
une fois sur deux normalement bon
n'hésitez pas à nous dire en tout cas on
a très très beau match aujourd'hui avec
on va voir ça tout de suite en images
mon cher
mon cher Kévin avec goukesh face à ouais
mais alors là du coup vas-y parle et ben
je vais parler à nouveau Laurent
on s'entend ouais donc tu disais tu
parlais de Jean-Pierre Leroux qui est le
qui émergent breton de tous les temps
finalement exactement est-ce que c'est
le seul grand maître hein c'est le seul
grand maître oui alors on a pierre
Belley qui est passé grand maître mais
qui est angevin niçois donc il s'est
rapproché de la Bretagne il habite sur
Rennes maintenant pierre qui est tout
nouveau grand maître mais de de joueurs
qui a joué tout le temps en Bretagne il
y a que Jean-Pierre Leroux qui a réussi
tout comme Jean-Noël riff en Alsace quoi
tu vois c'est c'est vraiment les les
légendes dans les dans les régions et
ben moi aussi à l'époque j'étais une
légende dans ma région en Aquitaine tu
vois chacun a été j'ai été le premier il
y a eu Mathieu cornette ensuite mais
depuis il y a plus personne et puis vous
avez réussi en plus au-delà de la
légende dans votre région quand même
avoir des résultats retentissants au
niveau national ce qui est encore autre
chose ouais mais surtout dans notre
région crois-moi quand je rentre dans
les Landes il me regarde comme enfin bon
bref non
du pays bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr ça
fait toujours plaisir évidemment en tout
cas Google c'est l'enfant du pays de
l'Inde et regardez-moi ça il joue pour
les California unicornes donc voilà
c'est la mondialisation il joue avec nos
amis américains il sera le leader
aujourd'hui on va voir les compositions
d'équipe
mais c'est un peu bizarre et en face on
a la team amener donc 100% indienne avec
un iranien qui s'est amintabatabae je
sais pas si j'ai aujourd'hui et en tout
cas avec Eric gazy Nara Diane tabataba
harika la très forte joueuse indienne et
beaucoup d'autres donc voilà on va
découvrir ses compos mon cher mon cher
Kevin je me suis gouré en bas oh là là
c'est c'est un début de stream je te
raconte pas pendant que tu nous parles
des compos tu nous fais des compos moi
je vais changer là les composés les noms
des équipes en fait parce que c'est bien
que j'ai pas de rater sur ces petits
détails là Laurent en plus
j'ai un petit peu d'être étonné que tu
es laissé traîner cela une petite gaffe
de Laurent dès le début du stream mais
sans logiciel de stream de plus en plus
c'est ça qui est inquiétant
alors donc tu peux nous dire les joueurs
tu peux nous dire les joueurs
il y a goûtes et clairement aryung
ergasi il joue sur les échiquiers
opposés ils sont chacun opposés aux
femmes de l'autre équipe
et ça joue souvent là dessus les les
femmes ont un gros emploi je trouve dans
ces matchs dès qu'elles arrivent à
inquiéter les les plus gros et l'eau bah
ça fait ça peut faire la différence donc
goket sera opposé à Arica et Ariane
reggaizi jouera contre Sabine à Foisor
alors normalement si on doit comparer
Arika et Sabina Foisor
Arika c'est grand maître mixte et Sabina
Foisor c'est
woman grande master donc c'est grand
maître féminin c'est pas du tout le même
standing on verra ça reste des parties
ultra rapide on est quasiment en blitz
en 10 + 2 on vous rappelle la cadence
ni sneak sera opposé à deeptime gauche
et autrement il y aura christophort you
contre adiban donc ils ont pas ils ont
pas tout à fait optimisé chez les
joueurs indiens ils pouvaient être
encore plus fort mais il faut rester
c'est pas mal du tout là attends a dit
ban il est à plus de 2006 gauche je sais
pas comment il a des lots mais il doit
avoir pas mal aussi je l'aurais bien je
l'aurais bien aligné mais il pouvait
peut-être pas
optimisé mais ça se trouve c'était pas
légal alors à mon avis c'est pas légal
je l'ai sous-entendu entre adiban
naranayan et harika c'est sûr c'est pas
légal en vrai
parce qu'ils ont beaucoup trop d'élots
nara.n il a quasiment 2007
colorant va nous rappeler justement les
règles à respecter les règles les règles
on les a les règles tu sais tu as fait
et
le temps quand même un piège voilà tu me
tends un piège tu vois parce que c'est
pas prêt donc 14 10 + 2 les compositions
d'équipe ne peuvent pas dépasser une
moyenne des lots de 2550 et donc en
sachant que les hommes sont capés à 2016
et les femmes à 2350 c'est-à-dire si on
a Magnus Carlsen ou argile ça ne change
rien ça compte comme un 2016 pareil chez
les femmes si on a une joie à 2005 et
bien ça ça compte exactement pareil
qu'une joueuse à 2004 voilà si vous
comprenez le truc la première équipe on
joue donc contre les quatre adversaires
première équipe à 8 et demi mon cher
Kevin peut-être des départages
évidemment un mot des tailles break
qu'on a vu on a vu deux fois depuis le
début et malheureusement
l'équipe de Blitz était les héros de la
première ronde en ayant battu au
tie-break leurs adversaires et hier soir
c'était un final a le temps je sais pas
Estelle tant de suivre Kevin pas de
suivre
j'ai suivi ça en direct et le drame le
drame avec
il s'est passé Blitz qui
méritait en fait c'est toujours le
vainqueur qui le mérite mais bon avec
Maxime Vacher Lagrave qui
malheureusement c'est complètement
écroulé contre inches en perdant le
dernier rapide et le Blitz
assez comme Maxime un joueur de génie
mais qui peut avoir des petits passages
à vide c'est ça a toujours été un peu
comme ça et malheureusement
c'était hier le petit passage à vide la
cadence amène cela aussi d'excellents
joueurs peuvent craquer en fait tout ça
il faut le voir moi j'ai pas vu venir le
2-0 contre inches le 02 contre une teach
sachant connaissant bien les deux
joueurs
talent tu vois Maxime quand il s'y met
tu vois c'est quand même c'est le génie
le génie absolue et là voilà il s'est
coulait fatigué
pas la même classe de Grand Maître donc
c'est c'est vrai que c'est étonnant
maintenant la cadence amène un peu plus
de variance tout à fait et donc là on a
vous voyez avec les Blancs on sait pas
du tout qui c'est mais on va évidemment
se mettre sympa le petit salon ouais
sympa le petit salon et en face on sait
pas du tout qui c'est non plus et bien
voilà donc c'est là où on en est pour le
réglage c'est caméra donc va falloir
attendre un petit peu de voir tout ce
beau monde arriver vous voyez
alors lui non plus on sait pas qui c'est
lui et les siècle c'est qui lui vont
faire mon cher Kevin
tu as pas la RAF hein
alors attends si si Christophe
ouais
donc de quoi voilà c'est quasiment sûr
tu as raison tu as raison on va on va le
renommer notre mini-jnique en plus tu
vas nous tu vas nous trouver les
appariements ça va être génial on voit
des cheveux là il faut non c'est des
cheveux qu'on voit il y a la petite et
un dernier petit point je voulais
t'apprendre un truc
j'ai oublié dernier petit point on va on
va faire un petit point classement
je vais t'apprendre quelque chose mon
petit mon petit Kevin tu vas être épaté
par mes talents ça va être ça va être
énorme regarde ça sous tes yeux ébahis
tu vas voir le classement le classement
apparaître avec des équipes en verte si
tu pourquoi deux équipes sont en vertes
Kevin
quand l'équipe était en rouge tu nous a
dit qu'elle était éliminée et d'ailleurs
il y en a une en rouge je veux dire
qui a 5 semaines dans 5 matchs si vous
avez trois sur cinq vous êtes sûrs
donc deux équipes qualifiées les Indian
yugiz et les Gotham Knights emmenés par
Hikaru Nakamura bien évidemment donc il
faut faire en fait trois sur cinq donc
là ils ont trois sur trois donc ils ne
jouent plus jusqu'au jusqu'au playoff
tandis qu'on voit Blitz qui est tombé
qui est là qui est avec une victoire
pour deux défaites donc ils sont pas en
rouge ils sont pas en vert
voilà il faut maintenant gagner les deux
prochains matchs il faut déjà gagner le
match la semaine prochaine pour s'offrir
une finale évidemment on suivra ça chez
nos amis de Blitz stream et aujourd'hui
regarde on a les California unique
Unicorn voilà qui ont une victoire une
défaite contre la team MGD 1 donc d'Inde
une victoire une défaite aussi donc soit
il passe dans la zone quasi verte tu
vois soit il passe dans la zone rouge
mais il y a pas d'élimination en tout
cas aujourd'hui tu as pris un truc ou
pas ils seront en vie pas grand chose du
coup puisque j'ai déduit assez
facilement en fait il suffit de suivre
quoi
ah c'est dégueulasse que tu fais qui est
en face de qui est en face de niche
t'as pas on se demande qui
apprend à l'autre il va falloir il va
falloir faire mieux on va l'enlever
ça c'est harryka voilà donc on va est-ce
que les tu me dis quand une partie a
commencé s'il te plaît
avait le mug Chacom ah c'est beau ça
ça c'est Hannibal
notre personnalisé là du coup alors
Adiba attention c'est un joueur hyper
spectaculaire un style je t'envoie tout
et je réfléchis ensuite
donc c'est en général très très sympa à
suivre ce genre de cadence c'est bien on
a goûté ici le traître non je plaisante
évidemment
on est tous
on est tous à fait bizarre mais
évidemment tout le monde joue pour pour
tout le monde d'ailleurs le traître en
parlant de ça moi j'ai joué pour
énormément contre les Français donc tu
vois je suis assez à l'aise avec ça
pardon c'est bien ton style de traître
et après de dire ah bah non finalement
je peux pas dire ça finalement je l'ai
fait finalement je l'ai fait aussi donc
c'est pas si grave tu vois
salut à toi chasse comme effet n'hésite
pas à nous dire s'il marche bien on le
remercie ou là qui c'est ça c'est gauche
je vois pas je vois pas d'autres je
pense que c'est goche ouais dis donc je
n'ai jamais vu lui forcer mais je
connaissais pas non plus
ça pousse en dinde en Inde les grands
maîtres
ils poussent pas dans les arbres mais
quasiment c'est quand même oui des
gauches il y en a peut-être plus
plusieurs et donc on voit quand même
très corpo il a mis le t-shirt de la
pros ligue
ça c'est corpo
alors est-ce qu'il y a des parties qui
ont commencé mon cher le t-shirt et son
nom d'équipe et on voit Sabina fois il
sort
si tu pouvais m'aider sur le c'est la
troisième fois normalement je pense que
tu vas commencer à m'écouter
tu pouvais m'aider sur la partie sur une
partie commencer
alors est-ce que tu veux que je regarde
Laurent s'il est parti
donc en fait l'idée c'est c'est qu'on
bosse on a compris ce qui a commencé tu
vois par exemple mais bon c'est pas
normalement c'est toi qui gère la
technique donc je pensais que tu avais
plus besoin de moi mais bon je vais
vraiment je vais faire attention
d'accord je te remercie donc Google
est-ce qu'elle est noire contre la comme
tu le disais la Grand Maître la Grand
Maître indienne harika et on voit elle
joue elle joue très serré car on la
connaît
le chat est en mode abonné
mais ça a été fait donc je pensais que
c'était délibéré alors allez-y
abonnez-vous c'est gratuit de s'abonner
ou pas attends je vais essayer de
m'abonner
c'est pas gratuit c'est de suivre qui
est gratuit
[Musique]
j'écouterai ces conseils avec plus de
tu vois
plus de réserve donc bienvenue à tous
c'est pour ça que personne ne parlait et
voilà donc n'hésitez pas surtout à vous
abonner et allez-y ou au moins à nous
suivre sur YouTube sur twitch évidemment
youtube il y a les deux chaînes 16 24 fr
ou cheesecom FR et on voit une variante
d'échange de la française qu'est-ce que
tu en penses Kévin alors la vente
d'échange normalement on peut pas la
jouer au niveau sauf avec un relief 3
dites un peu variante Bacro j'appelle ça
comme ça parce que on a Étienne qui joue
ça très régulièrement quand même dans la
base de données c'est une c'est vraiment
intéressant j'avais étudié ça pour la
première fois avec LG relo qui vient de
voir souvent dans le chat il avait des
matchs de top jeune avait envie de jouer
ce variante avec cavalier F3 ici qui est
très précis
qu'il cou logique en général je sais pas
si c'est ce que tu dis à tes élèves mais
de développer les cavaliers avant les
fous parce que là on voit très bien le
cavalier de géant il va aller en F3
c'est à peu près clair donc pourquoi pas
le faire tout de suite et il est fou on
sait jamais sur un ksi6 on peut tenter
un petit clouage en général c'est plutôt
là la case du Fou l'autre cas c'est
plutôt là ou là on sait jamais on peut
retenter un petit clouage si le cavalier
vient ici donc on sait pas encore pour
les foutres est-ce que pour le cavalier
ça semble à peu près clair concrètement
Laurent et tu me posais la question de
savoir si j'en parlais à mes élèves oui
et j'appelle ça même le principe de
souplesse et je trouve je me trouvais
assez malin de dire ça Laurent je
pensais que j'étais un des seuls tu vois
et j'utilise ce mot la souplesse je
trouvais ça cool et en lisant un bouquin
de mainson
où il y avait un chapitre qui s'appelait
la souplesse j'ai compris que je n'étais
pas le seul détenteur de cette
expression voilà tout simplement et
c'est joli Mondy je trouve j'aime bien
démonstration de la souplesse les fous
sont plus souples c'est vrai c'est vrai
qu'on développe les cavaliers en premier
exactement et ils ont moins de ils sont
moins souples les cavaliers en fait
aussi exactement ils ont une case
naturelle en plus en 3 et 3 normalement
donc là elle joue ça bon clairement on
va pas se mentir à sa mission pour cette
partie c'est essayer de faire nul
clairement elle a pas d'ambition comme
peuvent la voir soit Étienne macro soit
manuscrit qui a joué ça aussi il a
beaucoup joué ça Magnus non pas vraiment
il a joué ça une ou deux fois et en fait
Magnus si je jouais ça c'est marrant
parce qu'il jouait ça contre la contre
la pétrole la pétrole bien sûr ouais
4 et la D3 un petit coup de D3 qui est
F6 des 4 D5 et on voit c'est une
transposition alors bon on a joué un
coup de plus mais ça change rien au fait
que ça soit exactement la même position
finalement qui est intéressant avec les
Blancs je trouve que
c'est un bon système Laurent économique
pour pas mal de jours amateurs je les
conseille à quelques élèves ce système
là ouais c'est vrai que la française
tout à fait les lots sous les sous les
caméras ce sont les hello fidèles donc
on voit 2507 pour Arika qui en fait
d'elle des
10 joueuses une dizaine de joueuses qui
ont plus de 2500 hellophidés donc
une cliente très très sérieuse et on
voit ce on voit déjà à Google qui joue
assez agressif en général c'est un truc
c'est un truc d'attaque tout ça
peut-être cavalière 4 qui va venir ici
et voilà bon ça va être intéressant à
suivre évidemment on va faire peut-être
un petit un petit tour des stades
ça t'amuse toujours parce que tu sais
bien que il faut que je change de caméra
et quand je change de caméra c'est
quelque chose qui te plaît parce que un
petit peu d'ailleurs depuis le début du
stream Laurent pour pour tout te dire
ouais c'est ça et donc gauche qu'on va
qu'on va tout de suite voir apparaître à
l'écran face à notre ami nijnic et voilà
gauche qu'on connaissait pas tous les
deux et on voit une sorte de c'est pas
une sorte c'est une mer en
et voilà où ça se ça s'échange 2550
contre 2650 donc vous voyez une partie
plus ou moins équilibrée parce que quand
même les la centaine de points et l'eau
souvent compensé par les la couleur
c'est à dire le fait d'avoir les noirs
donc ça joue solide des deux côtés
[Musique]
à cause de fou des deux qui qui gênait
un petit peu le faux B4 alors
ça c'est des c'est ce que j'appelle
alors comme tu disais tu es tu parlais
de tes expressions de souplesse moi
c'est ce que j'appelle c'est comme la
berlinois c'est des fausses c'est des
fausses finales avec tout sans les dames
mais où il y a encore toutes les pièces
mineures et tout et les tours c'est faut
faire attention c'est des milieux de jeu
sans les dames voilà j'appelle ça comme
ça parce que finalement le roi E7 c'est
pas complètement clair qui sera à l'abri
parce qu'il reste quand même tu vois je
peux je peux m'organiser les choses
comme ça faut F4 c'est pas l'abri d'un
échec de moins surprise donc louage même
par là donc il faut faire attention et
en général moi je préfère aussi plutôt
ok quand il reste autant de pièces sur
l'échiquier
c'est un peu frileux donc
[Musique]
c'est marrant quand même qu'il fasse
petit Rogue roi recette tu sais Laurent
c'est vrai que il va pas faire recette
je pense quand même là parce que c'est
ridicule tu vois de je pense que il met
le roi par là mais j'aime pas ce qu'il
fait pour être tout à fait bizarre c'est
bizarre d'avoir refait roi F8 mais bon
et je suis pas le seul la jauge aime
bien les blancs parce que regardez ce
fou c'est comme dans la cabine à
accepter si on a le fond en V7 contre F3
il est pas prêt de jouer donc on peut
imaginer ici quelque chose comme faux F2
suivi de 4 et on va jouer contre ce foot
casse blanche qui va être un vrai souci
pour les Noirs d'argent de structure yes
on voit souvent sur des positions assez
difficiles à jouer alors bon les joueurs
sont forts à très très haut niveau je
trouve que dans ces positions à
structures symétrique les blancs font
les Noirs font facilement nuls mais dans
ce genre de de confrontation avec la
cadence rapide c'est une bonne galère de
jouer ça avec avec les Noirs jamais très
agréable j'ai toujours été content ici
avec les Blancs
alors on va voir maintenant le fantasque
à dyban avec les Noirs contre eux
Christopher
donc voilà
hop là on le voit Christopher you qui a
pas l'air très très concerné par la
partie mais on voit une sorte d'attaque
astonienne en premier vous cherchez un
bon système contre la française sans
vous prendre la tête ce que je voulais
blancs ici c'est vraiment le top du top
parce qu'en plus les joueurs amateurs
joueront pas très bien ce genre de
position je peux vous le dire suite et
j'aime beaucoup voilà le jeu on ferme le
centre on peut le dire et après on
exploite une attaque à aller le roi
alors là le hadyban c'est un pro il a
joué
pour empêcher mais sinon ça arrive alors
tout à fait tout à fait des parties de
Fisher à l'époque qui qui m'a testé
l'adversaires alors maintenant c'est
censé
les Noirs en tout cas sont censés avoir
des antidotes mais c'est hyper compliqué
ça reste très très compliqué et
complètement jouable niveau amateur même
d'ailleurs on le voit proches League il
a 2589 contre 2610 donc ça reste jouable
à tous les niveaux
déjà fait je pense que c'est très
venimeux un niveau amateur pour ceux qui
ont envie de regarder l'indienne en
premier attaque est indienne voilà qui a
pour certains du coup
aller regarder ça c'est ça ça vaut quand
même le coup donc là on avec la
Française des changes cavalier F3 qu'on
a vu beaucoup plus plate et cette
ouverture pour ceux qui aiment l'attaque
vous avez de quoi faire contre si vous
n'aimez pas la française quand vous avez
E4 avec les Blancs quand vous jouez le 4
avec les Blancs allez vers cela tout à
fait et on voit déjà à 10 balles rien
que ça déco tu vois elle est quand même
elle est travaillée tu vois dans son non
mais tu vois il y a un truc quoi c'est
pas une déco tu vois bah l'autre il a
une lampe une lumière enfin tu vois bon
normal quoi un mur blanc et adivan tu
sens que bon c'est déjà il se passe plus
de choses dans son cerveau quoi tu vois
il réfléchit au truc c'est quoi
à côté de la lampe je sais pas
[Musique]
si vous avez trouvé à côté de la lampe
on sait pas à vibromasseur peut-être
alors
regarde pas et on va voir la dernière la
dernière partie entre Eric et easy
peut-être la partie c'est même sûr la
partie la plus déséquilibrée sur le
papier entre Sabina foyers 2185 alors ça
c'est quand même très très étonnant
parce que c'est une joueuse qui avait
beaucoup plus d'élo que ça donc beaucoup
plus dangereuse que 2185 face à harjoon
erikasi et on voit encore une fois une
ouverture solide de la part des blancs
on essaie de tenir clairement
donc bon on va prendre le foot très
forte dans la
famille foisort une famille de joueurs
d'échec tout à fait
tout à fait on avait discuté l'autre
jour d'ailleurs et c'est vrai que c'est
rare que elle est elle est grand maître
internationale féminin et donc comme ça
ça maman
deux parents étaient mettre un snow
mixte voilà c'est ça exactement
elle a gagné un des grands tournois elle
est très très connu en France elle
gagnait elle gagnait des Open
donc voilà une famille de joueurs mais
là c'est dur c'est dur déjà elle est pas
très bien
j'aime pas c'est trop passif ce qu'elle
a fait on a froid déjà
il y a un monde d'écart on va pas se
mentir ouais clairement
on va voir il s'est passé énormément de
choses chez chez Arica et Google on va
peut-être aller les voir
avec Google qui va essayer évidemment
d'apporter un point
de de battre
tu sais après tu gagnes le droit de
chambrette et à tes potes hein c'est pas
mal de jouer contre une équipe amie
c'est sympa si tu gagnes
celle-là Laurent
c'est toujours sympa ouais moi j'ai ça
fait toujours un peu peur je sais pas si
tu es comme ça TOI mais jouer contre ses
potes alors c'est sympa
tout dépend du statut aussi tu vois
bon imaginons je compte toi bon si je
perds tout le monde va trouver ça normal
donc pas de pression par contre toi et
toi qui a la pression tu sais bien moi
tous les ans au top tu connais beaucoup
de monde il y a des joueurs qu'on quitte
aimerait bien éviter de faire nul ou de
perdre ça m'est arrivé ça m'est arrivé
et je lui ai dit tu seras en plus j'ai
fait tu sais que j'ai fait un très bon
top 16 genre
invaincu trois vitres je suis plus trois
victoires bon bref ça allait quoi de
très bon top 16 organiseur des points
hello enfin tu vois en faisant ce qu'il
faut pour pour l'équipe mais c'est ce
que j'ai dit à Pierre bon écoute moi je
considère qu'il est raté
que tu étais quand même tu m'as trop
déçu quoi et donc pierre c'est vrai que
que l'on salue le maître international
pierre Barbot que j'ai eu comme
coéquipier pendant 10 ans à Clichy et
qui qui est un bon caractère très et en
fait c'est un souffle en douleur pendant
deux semaines et donc il se fait
chambrer
et donc une fois j'étais capitaine je
vais raconter parce que j'ai pas raconté
encore ici tu vois j'étais capitaine de
Barbie ça à Clichy et donc il fait il
fait un coup illégal c'est à dire qu'il
va pouvoir gérer son roi puis finalement
il est sur échec donc il va pour bouger
son roi puis finalement ils vont appuyer
en prise il aime bien manger quand même
donc il mange le pion et donc il y a son
grand reprise et donc son adversaire lui
dit quoi illégal et là il me regarde il
me dit mais qu'est-ce que je fais
maintenant
je lui ai dit d'essayer de jouer des
coups légaux
mais déjà j'étais mort de rire enfin tu
vois
j'imagine mais il me semble que c'est on
a parlé de la légende bretonne
Jean-Pierre Leroux il me semble que
c'est dans notre match à Montpellier qui
a un vieux match où il avait fait où
illégal contre toi Jean-Pierre en
faisant grand rock alors qu'il avait
déjà bougé son roi alors c'est contre
toi il me semble il se trouve que ouais
ouais et en plus j'avais gagné cette
partie quand même mais c'est un bon coup
non mais c'est un bon coup roi des 8 en
fait ça le forçait à jouer le cookie qui
me que je considérait comme le meilleur
d'accord ok donc j'ai réfléchi en fait
je me rappelle très bien de ce truc où
j'ai réfléchi deux trois secondes tu
vois que la malice qui me caractérise en
me disant est-ce que c'est pas mieux que
je laisse faire grand rock finalement
parce que je considère croiser 8 qui
était le seul coup légal parce qu'il
doit bouger son roi quand vous touchez
une pièce vous devez la bouger même si
vous faites un coup illégal et donc je
considérais roi David comme le meilleur
coup donc j'avais léchi un petit peu
pour savoir si c'était si je devais le
dire ou pas et je l'ai dit mon honnêteté
me perdra enfin et il a un pion de plus
gouquet il est quand même très très bien
le fou c'est un autre avantage
et ça y est il commence il commence la
journée le foot domine totalement
cavalier vous voyez et en plus on peut
pas se permettre d'échanger normalement
cavaliers en difficulté de matériel donc
c'est la galère là elle va bientôt
abandonner sauf drame mais tout à fait
tout à fait la technique de Google
LES PLUS déséquilibrés on démarre par
cela au départ Laurent donc c'est pas
normal que les deux jeunes femmes
voilà perdre tout simplement c'est vrai
c'est vrai que aux deux et au 3
finalement on a des quand même des
parties beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus équilibré tout simplement
on va aller voir on va aller voir ça
peut-être cette finale moi bon je trouve
ça wadiban hadyban quand même
normalement il nous fait le spectacle
allez on va voir à 10 balles contre
Christopher you je pense que tu en
penses mais c'est cool
salut Robinson
et
du coup Robinson qui nous raconte dans
le chat une de ces péripéties voilà lui
aussi
on lui a joué
un coup illégal un petit rock avec la
tour en 8 et il a joué cavalier G5 pour
forcer tout fit
très très bon tu vois alors il y a de la
malice partout ça c'est limite
c'est limite pour les autres vous avez
bien compris le message de Laurent
ici
en fait ouais justement sur H5 en fait
si ton adversaire joue H5 le meilleur
coup ici c'est de faire parce que tu
revenais pas tu revenais plus en arrière
donc en blitz le meilleur coup c'était
de jouer dame prend H5 et de dire échec
et donc en fait parce que tu ramasses la
tour du coup sur ces 6 tu prends tu
prends la tour donc après ils l'ont
changé règlement mais il était quand
même en vigueur pendant un an tu vois ou
en fait il te il te il t'incitait à
faire un hashtag objectivement le
meilleur coup pour
améliorer tes chances de gains
c'est-à-dire en terme d'équité c'était
de faire des échec voilà pour le pour la
petite la petite histoire donc on n'est
pas obligé je sais pas alors évidemment
l'exemple le plus connu je sais pas si
tu le connais mon cher Kévin mais c'est
drive Kasparov dans une casperia pardon
dans une dans un rapide très connu où
drief à un moment on fait tout reprend
H5 la tour revient à la suite et 10
coups plus tard il fait petit rock et
les Garrick astarov n'a rien remarqué
son adversaire a priori pas fait exprès
et ça a continué comme ça et je sais
plus ce qui s'est passé dans la partie à
une île où au castor a gagné
donc maintenant revient au coup illégal
même plusieurs coups en arrière ouais je
crois que il y a deux trois coups pour
ce si un arbitre dans le ici il y a deux
trois coups pour revenir au coup illégal
à partir de deux trois coups c'est
validé
peut-être que la règle a changé mais je
croyais qu'on pouvait revenir
indéfiniment en partie lente je parle
au moment du coup illégal en tout cas
cette règle là était en vigueur Laurent
après c'est les rapides c'est différent
en partie lente je suis pas sûr parti
lente bon je me rappelle de d'avoir vu
une partie d'Olivier René quand j'étais
plus jeune où il avait dû revenir et il
avait abandonné du coup parce que dans
le zaynote il y avait eu coup illégal et
j'ai une camarade bretonne claire
bodenes je sais pas si tu l'as connu qui
était joué à 2000 qui jouait un tournoi
de maître féminin contre tétanquina
grand maître féminin à 2250 à peu près
et elle avait fait dame 1 en B3 clair
pour accélérer l'attaque à l'eldame donc
bon c'est pas forcément bon vous voyez
ça change un peu de diagonale et son
adversaire n'avait rien dit 10 coups
plus tard avantages pour mon ami
bretonne c'est exactement ce que je
voulais dire c'est que c'est cette règle
là elle est pas bonne parce que tu peux
revenir exactement
10 coups plus tard quand elle est elle a
commencé à être mal et du coup bah voilà
la piste des pièces touchées pièces à
jouer la partie a continué mais c'était
pas du tout la même config et que Claire
bonnet c'est un peu un peu dégoûté à
lâcher complètement la partie voilà euh
non alors je sais pas exactement si on a
un arbitre dans le chat un orbite
compétent ceci n'est pas un oxymore Gaïa
parfois Gaïa et des fois dans le chat je
sais pas si elle est là aujourd'hui je
crois qu'elle travaille un petit peu
donc du coup le vendredi elle arrive un
peu plus tard j'adore j'adore j'adore
balancer sur les arbitres tu sais c'est
très populaire comme truc parce qu'en
général on a tous une histoire avec un
arbitre qu'on aime pas ouais mais ce qui
est bien c'est que tu attends de
vérifier qu'il y ait pas trop d'arbitre
dans le chat donc
je suis surbrouillé avec un homme
d'arbitre tu peux pas t'imaginer
donc enfin à brouiller gentiment mais
bon au bout d'un moment ouais enfin bon
bref non mais quand quand le type a rien
à faire et qu'il le fait mal quand il a
un truc à faire c'est un peu énervant
mais il y a des il y a des mauvais
arbitres comme il y a des mauvais
joueurs comme il y a des tu vois par des
tout partout c'est toujours pareil bien
sûr salut à tous Jacques gare mon
bouquin sort quand il sort pas mon
bouquin j'ai pas de bouquins c'est assez
bol c'est pas c'est un bouquin en ligne
et on sait pas on sait pas même moi je
sais pas parce qu'il est pas encore
écrit et c'est toujours
c'est ça le problème on cherche encore
c'est quand on n'a pas écrit la moitié
là je suis à Laurent tu fais des gros
teasers toi je suis allé 25% vendant
dans le dos
ça fait 6 mois que j'y suis dessus donc
vous voyez
j'ai pas encore passé la seconde c'est
comme
un rôle non en fait je fais des petites
pauses
j'ai fait une petite pause de deux mois
j'ai absolument rien écrit tout ce que
je raconte est vrai en plus c'est ça qui
est horrible
les gens se disent
et il rigole et tout ça non non j'ai
fait une pause de deux mois je sentais
pas
du fractionné
[Musique]
avec Kevin tu vois alors on est bien on
commente choisir
c'est sûr que c'est pas facile non mais
l'aspect effectivement que ce soit des
bouquins ou des vidéos quand tu es tout
seul face à ton ordi il faut le dire que
c'est c'est moins dynamique bah faut se
motiver réellement quoi ah ouais ouais
ouais c'est quand même
c'est quand même incroyable Michael
Klein
les gars alors attention moi j'en ai
chez moi c'est collector ils en
produisent plus même en Chine vous en
trouverez pas ils sont là ils sont là
moi je les garde c'est jamais j'en ai un
j'en ai un Laurent que tu m'avais
gentiment offert lors d'un passage chez
toi
je peux penser à toi ah ça fait plaisir
mais c'est vrai qu'en général les gens
qui étaient le passage chez moi
[Rires]
j'ai pas envie de te faire un cadeau je
vais payer bon laisse-moi te faire un
cadeau que je ne paye pas alors on va
revenir aux échecs et on voit que Google
a remporté sa finale et ni je nique a
gagné contre gauche qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé dans cette partie alors ça c'est
étonnant ah il s'est fait avoir dans la
finale alors ça c'est un petit peu
étonnant parce qu'on aimait bien les
blancs et petit à petit ah mais c'est
pris une tactique
bon le Fou est meilleur de la paumée et
là c'est un peu exemple si tu bouges le
roi je viens et il a dû bouger le hyper
un pion et la partie donc de zéro déjà
pour la Californie donc Hannibal la
partie Hannibal est très en comptant que
Eric et va très certainement l'emporter
la partie à 10 balles est très
importante et moi qui est F3 menace
maths oui bien 10 balles
en grande difficulté c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire
comment on fait
là on fait plus
on est dans les cordes avec le D4 qui
pourrait arriver à un moment aussi alors
attention il faut baisser pour l'instant
il en a l'air
donc des quatre air très très fort et
surtout huit on fait simplement tout
reprend dam prend étourée échec à la
découverte terminado et donc il a fait
tourner
toute façon ça a l'air complètement
gagnant pour prendre et pas possible il
y a ceux cavalier qui peut pas aller
qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire là peut-être
tout recettes pour menacer mat ça va
crise quand même parce que
[Musique]
c'est pas fini
donc maintenant on va se diriger vers un
nul je crois mais attends tour 8 jouer
des quatre c'est un peu chaud non
j'essaie de faire croire qu'il y a du
suspens quand même vas-y je peux rejouer
à nouveau Decathlon et des 4 a été joué
par hadyban 2 secondes pour trouver
miracle n'existe pas et c'est perdu
et maintenant j'ai tous les échecs à la
découverte du monde alors qu'est-ce qui
nous fait arioun
c'est marrant la position des pions
triplés c'est une vraie catastrophe pour
pour Sabina Foisor
on a retrouvé Ariane reggaizer regardez
à la technique Laurent aujourd'hui les
cames ça change vite dans tous les jours
c'est tous les jours comme ça en fait
c'est des plus poussif au début non mais
vraiment il y a du progrès là
franchement on apprécié
quand même le meilleur
et pourtant je me suis pas mis en route
aujourd'hui là je dois avouer que c'est
le show que j'ai le moins préparé
maintenant
ouais Sabina
elles peuvent abandonner aussi avec une
tour de moi contre
ergamesis ça ne pardonne pas fu F3 et on
s'attend un abandon de Sabina Faso et de
partout ok intéressant la plus de temps
bon donc c'était la cata non mais c'est
trop dur enfin là il y a vraiment on
parle de 500 points hello d'écart alors
oui elle peut c'est une partie je sais
pas sur combien c'est pas une partie sur
100 qu'elle va gagner enfin dans ce
contexte là 10 + 2 pas en gagner
beaucoup hein oui non c'est sûr surtout
que c'est il est très fort très fort à
partir rapide évidemment et très fort
donc il y avait pas trop de parties mais
la partie importante finalement pour les
indiens pour rester un petit peu au
contact et à de partout c'était cette
partie d'hadyban face à Christopher you
13 points point important et ça nous
donne un match nul et ça nous donne je
pense on va avoir un match tendu ça pas
comme la trière
qui ont été la seule équipe a remporter
deux matchs sans avoir à jouer le 4e 7
c'est à dire qu'ils seront ils ont
atteint 8 et demi et même plus hier 9-3
après simplement 12 parties jouées au
lieu de 16 ce qui était assez
impressionnant c'est vraiment peut-être
les grands favoris de cette compète
donc bon voilà c'est le moment un peu un
peu tranquille petite pause j'en profite
Laurent pour dire qu'on a gagné au
badminton aussi mercredi
j'étais toujours pas dit
c'est important bravo
tu vois c'est comme ça que ça se passe
le genre de chat qui va faire du sport
et ce matin je me suis levé j'avais pris
20 ans quoi bravo
et ben pour une fois alors que ça nous
est jamais arrivé d'espérer avec notre
petite équipe de village pour une fois
on est en passe de jouer pour la montée
effectivement Laurent donc
on a pris 7 ans qu'on les premiers parce
qu'il y a une sacrée équipe de premier
ils sont invincibles ils mettent des
raclées à tout le monde mais on est en
passe de monter en Ligue 2 en Ligue 2 ce
serait beau ça serait beau
voilà alors Michael keh t'as vu Mikey
Willis qui
commence ses enchères à 40 euros
Michael attends c'est collector s'il te
plaît
quand même on rajoute un - 0 et après on
commence à discuter ah ouais tu es comme
ça ah bah oui tu sais faut
plus ça passe j'ai mon petit goodies qui
traîne à la maison à 40 faut réfléchir
c'est un cadeau j'ai accepté un cadeau
mais
[Rires]
oui comme à la mode tu sais tu vas au
culot tu fais croire c'est collector
tout ça ouais
donc est-ce qu'on serait pas un petit
point classement par rapport à aux gens
qui nous rejoignent allez pour qu'ils
comprennent quelque chose à ce qui se
passe éveillez pas là le placement mais
il est là avec c'est Indian yuriz façade
Gotham et gothamnights qui sont
qualifiés pour la phase finale nos amis
de Blitz qui ont perdu hier un match
rageant c'est vraiment rageant face à
face
et du coup on va pouvoir lui relayer la
question de Laurent tout à l'heure qui
concernait l'arbitrage Gaïa en cas de
coups illégal est-ce que tu confirmes si
aucun des deux joueurs ne le signale sur
le moment qu'on peut revenir par exemple
15 coups plus tard on peut revenir
indéfiniment à la position de base ou le
coût illégal a été effectué ou non on
aimerait bien voir ta réponse si tu en
as une sur le sujet de quand est-ce
qu'on peut revenir sur un coup illégal
ça va peut-être changer donc on avait
besoin de ta réponse et de ton
expérience salut à toi gaillard je sais
pas qui c'est Gaïa
d'après toi c'est une arbitre compétente
exactement oui en cadence lente voilà et
ça c'est pas normal tu vois c'est genre
de truc qui pourrait m'énerver même si
j'ai arbitre pas tort mais tu vois
le règlement
j'aime pas la règle alors
des fois il y a des raisons un petit peu
bizarres non mais moi ce qui m'est
arrivé je vais te raconter un truc où
vraiment j'étais pas content sur le sur
le truc
berline Beers contre Saint Louis on
suivra pas ce match c'est le c'est le
match suivant vous invite à aller sur la
chaîne anglaise pour suivre tout ça le
match pour la pour la voiture balai ben
c'est ça en fait c'est que le perdant
est éliminé mais le gagnant revient
finalement auteur de c'est à
hauteur des des autres équipes qui
peuvent se qualifier
ouais moi j'ai un truc où mon adversaire
si tu veux il joue son 40e coup et avec
une seconde en fait il voit il fait
tomber la moitié des chéquiers en gros
et en fait au lieu de remettre les
pièces il appuie sur la pendule parce
qu'il voit qu'il va tomber
en fait ça a compté comme un coup de
légal alors que
je quand même je
j'arrive en fait l'arbitre pour que j'ai
parti gagner et en fait tous les
arbitres te diront que c'est un coup
illégal donc en fait tu peux voir si tu
as une seconde tu appuies sur la pendule
sans jouer un coup
et en fait c'est bon
qui va pas
la vérifier ce point cette semaine
auprès d'un arbitre encore plus capé et
du coup c'est plutôt cocasse et oui oui
c'est tu as raison on met sur le point
de la logique tu vois et ça a pas de
logique ça a pas une logique sportive
sportif c'est jusqu'à parce que j'étais
Stern équipe de France je parlais à
Mazet et un moment l'arbitre a dit
attends je parle à Mazet je parle à
l'arbitre et après je parle à Mazet et
l'arbitre je m'attendais pas à ce qu'il
parle français tu vois cette suédois il
a dit attention je parle français quand
même bon
je suis vraiment désolé c'est tout ce
que j'ai pu penser avoir hôte un moment
douté de votre compétence excusez-moi
non mais en fait on la règle doit être
faite pour éviter que les joueurs
fassent justement volontairement des
cours mais justement en fait c'est là où
je fais reproche aux arbitres c'est que
souvent
c'est l'esprit de la règle le plus
important que la règle tu vois
ouais tu voudrais peut-être un peu plus
d'interprétation dans cette forêt là à
mon avis c'est mal interprété
c'est cette règle est mal interprétée
par là et tous les arbitres te diront la
même chose et je pense qu'il faut une
erreur tout en te disant que c'est
Girls geesen qui leur a dit
qui saigne arbitrer qu'un pauvre
castorvan il est très gentil mais
moi pour moi il faut une erreur parce
que
pourquoi ils font il faut une erreur
parce que ils savent pas souvent il
manque un peu de pratique à haut niveau
de pratique de compétition c'est ça
certains en tout cas pas tous évidemment
mais certains manque de pratique de
joueurs et donc voilà
donc c'est un peu voilà je pense que
cette règle-là elle devrait j'aurais dû
avoir victoire bon j'ai gagné en fait
c'est ça c'est ce truc je râle mais en
fait j'avais deux pions de plus et
j'étais archi gagnant mais il y a eu un
tu vois mais c'est quand même j'ai dû
que j'ai continué j'ai joué une heure de
plus j'ai gagné
mais je pense que j'aurais fait appel si
j'étais foutu j'aurais fait
à partir j'aurais fait à peine parce que
en tout cas le chat de s'anime avec
katchoupi qui nous dit que l'esprit de
la règle c'est le titre de mon prochain
bouquin justement et c'est beau ca
T'choupi bravo maintenant
alors le très bien mis c'était très bien
mis et on a excité
magnovitch là qui nous dit combien de
temps dure une proposition de nulle
exemple une personne propose nul au
début du tour de l'autre joueur qui
déconcentré par la proposition n'a pas
vu l'échec au roi et bouche à Dame
l'arbitre est appelé dame toucher dame
jouet le seul coup possible étant donc
de sacrifier sa dame sans aucune
contrepartie est-il possible d'accepter
la nul proposée pour moi non non parce
que dès que tu touches la dame alors
c'est pour moi je suis pas arbitre est
entamé pour pour moi donc il faut il
faut proposer nul en jouant son coup
c'est ça la règle sinon c'est si on
propose nul au milieu de la réflexion
sur l'adversaire c'est on peut appeler
l'arbitre en disant il m'a déconcentré
donnez-moi deux minutes voilà
exact
donc avant d'appuyer tout à fait ouais
Gaïa
ça m'arrive ça m'est arrivé qu'on
propose nul même des joueurs quelqu'un
qui est directeur général de la fille
dès maintenant tu vois
en plein milieu de ma réflexion vraiment
très très incorrect
ouais pour pour fragiliser le galaran et
du coup après tu l'avais collé j'ai fini
vraiment pour le sanctionner j'ai dit
oui tout de suite moi j'ai refusé j'ai
refusé j'ai joué mais bon c'était moins
bien j'étais pas terrible
oui non la proposition en elle-même
était correcte tu vois mais juste il
doit pas la faire en fait tu vois la
proposition était normale je veux dire
il a le droit de proposer nul mais il
doit le faire
et ce qu'on peut vous dire d'ailleurs
par rapport aux propositions nulle en
général je vais pour si vous voulez
progresser jouer tout le temps pour
gagner c'est à dire n'acceptez pas les
nuls sauf si vous êtes vraiment foutu
pourquoi pas mais c'est une véritable
arme cette proposition nulle pour
déstabiliser les adversaires puisque
même si vous continuez elle peut trotter
un petit peu en tête cette proposition
nulle et du coup des fois on voit des
joueurs qui refusent la nul c'est plutôt
courageux mais qui après dans le jeu ne
sont pas très courageux ne veulent plus
perdre comme si ça leur donnait le droit
du nul assurée ben non votre adversaire
vous a proposé une va falloir quand même
s'employer et c'est pas facile
psychologiquement de de tenir d'avoir
les nerfs pour aller la coller à la
personne quand la position encore tendue
voilà voilà on va essayer de jouer
tout à fait il faut jouer d'ailleurs
faut dire que manuscrit a quand même
lancé une mode
très très rare d'entendre Magnus Carlson
proposé nul et l'accepter il joue en
général jusqu'au bout et il a fait sa
carrière sur ça
en cherchant toujours à petite bête en
essayant de poser toujours la dernière
question s'il a 1 % de chance de gagner
ben il le prend parce que voilà quoi
donc faites
comme lui Laurent d'ailleurs tu m'avais
demandé de te prévenir quand ça
repartait ouais vas-y et du coup bah ces
choses faites j'ai eu des joueurs me
paraissait un peu
une fois j'ai même fait nul avec Magnus
et oui non je propose pas nul ah oui non
il a dit oui c'est ça oui la vidéo je
propose pas nul mais je propose une
répétition
j'oserai pas proposé la Magnus je peux
te dire que
c'est quelque chose qui n'arrive pas
mais effectivement
et oui dans vos premières nuls refusées
contre des joueurs plus forts on peut
perdre mais peu importe à la limite à
Laurent de toute façon si on apprend on
est obligé d'apprendre un par la défaite
souvent et du coup faut assumer pour
devenir plus fort demain
il y avait des joueurs je vous rappelle
de Tony miles à l'époque alors il est
vrai
un zona alors je parle d'un temps que
les moins de 20 ans ne peuvent pas
connaître et il se trouve que un de ses
collègues avait dit que il était et
c'est vrai qu'il c'était un très bon il
était très bon pour proposer la nul au
bon moment tu vois on sentait qu'il
faisait des bondiles tu vois il y a des
gens qui font des bondines quand même il
y en a moi mais comme dans la vie en
fait donc mais en général ouais je vous
conseille pas ça va pas être une arme
c'est pas un coup la proposition de nul
normalement mais tu vois ton image était
particulièrement doué pour sentir le
moment où son adversaire tu vois l'être
un peu moins sûr et quand il était moins
bien de proposer nul au bon moment
mais je trouve Laurent que c'est un peu
l'histoire de la chaîne alimentaire aux
échecs les gros et l'eau sentir mieux
que les petits hello dans dans ces
propositions nulles souvent c'est assez
malin c'est déstabilisant souvent le
gros et l'eau qui en abuse de ces
situations ne faites pas de tu sais tu
connais le proverbe c'est ce que me dit
Nilsen quand on discute ensemble de qui
va faire quoi il m'a dit je te conseille
de pas faire de deal avec les personnes
plus intelligentes que toi et donc Éléa
est derrière donc du coup il me propose
tout un tas de trucs
et donc il essaie de me balader voilà
donc c'est peut-être c'est pas plus
intelligent mais plus forte que ce soit
on va souvent on va souvent se faire
rouler dans la farine
donc s'il y a plus fort vous propose la
nul c'est qu'il y a sans doute un piège
parce qu'il est pas content de faire nul
contre vous il est content dans cette
situation où il se sent mal à l'aise de
faire nul contre vous voilà
un peu de psychologie est-ce que il y a
pas pu en prise
je passe du coq à l'âne là faut vérifier
moi je prends une fois et tu joues
alors
il y a des croquettes en plus donc
attends je peux pas jouer ça ouais
ouais et là tu vas tu me dis que tu as
des belles compensées
belle conception quand même
ouais très belle conception
nulle quand ton capitaine j'ai déjà fait
ça
on se connaît qu'elle T'choupi j'ai
l'impression j'ai fait à Monsieur Mulon
il m'a dit tu jouais à Cannes
aujourd'hui j'ai dit non il me dit mais
je t'interdit de proposer deux je dis
mais je ferai quand il y aura aux
toilettes et ça s'est passé exactement
comme ça
donc le mec a accepté tout de suite
c'est un joueur solide avec les Blancs
pas envie de d'aller chercher midi à 14h
et voilà c'est une belle
ah non c'est ah non c'est fait
donc dame 7 on protège tout ça
j'ai déjà raconté sur chaason 4 alors
c'est pas possible
en tout cas c'était mignon ça fait rire
on était pas très content aussi mais ça
a fait
au début donc ça le faisait pas trop
c'était au début voilà
au début de votre relation quoi c'est ça
qui est bien et pourquoi j'aime bien les
blancs parce que tu as pas de tu vois ce
pion va être faible il y a une
problématique de structure B5 est venu
fixer il y aura à 4 évidemment Laurent
évidemment sur les petits jeux de pions
malinovic et du coup
les blancs sont un peu mieux et du coup
c'est rude
petit tour des stades avec on va voir si
Erica arrive à se refaire elle a les
Noirs contre nijnic c'est pas un
appareil man facile on sait que
[Musique]
effectivement 50 points plus ça monte
plus c'est dur bien sûr donc plus il y a
il y a un gros écart et c'est pour ça
que Magnus ben il est ultra ultra
dominant parce qu'au niveau où il est
ben il met déjà 50 points en mec quoi et
il est à l'élite de l'élite donc c'est
normalement pas possible à ce point là
sauf bah chez castor off à une certaine
époque mais ça montre bien le niveau
qu'il a
tout à fait on fait comment là avec les
Blancs pour j'aime bien ça peut-être
pour aller là et puis on met celle qui
traîne aussi un petit peu quoi que ça
donnera un peu de jeu avec les Noirs
mais où est-ce qu'on va roquer est-ce
qu'on va vraiment faire petit rock moi
je suis inquiet pour ce roi en 8
tu vois je trouve qu'elle s'inquiète pas
trop tu vois si je fais ça par exemple
pour faire quelque chose comme ça
tu es chaud quand même intéressant en
tout cas la position est bordélique
c'est pas trop son style normalement
avec elle est beaucoup plus solide que
ça mais bon après c'est du jaune nine
rapide
j'ai trois pas mal proposé par ciel bleu
c'est vrai que maintenant quand on prend
on va reprendre du pion et la tour
tranquille à jouer et des blancs sont
mieux en tout cas c'est plus facile à
jouer au minimum
alors on a sinon Eric gazy avec les
Blancs cette fois le leader de l'équipe
indienne
face à
contre qui joue contre Christopher you
un jeune joueur américain très
c'est pas cher il regarde en bas j'ai
l'impression qu'il joue sur iPad
Christophe exactement depuis tout à
l'heure il est d'accord comme ça il joue
sur son téléphone peut-être
en tout cas la position obtenue était
bizarre donc c'est une trompe au ski
bon qui donne c'est la variante qui est
censé vraiment calmer les gens de
tonkowski qui a été vu notamment dans un
parti de championnats du monde la
première partie entre eux Maxus Carsen
et sergueïkine en 2016
il me l'a fait en Top 16 au début jojoba
donc c'est très dur de se préparer parce
que je m'étais préparé contre beaucoup
de choses
et beaucoup de petites choses alors pas
forcément extrêmement menaçante mais il
y a beaucoup il faut pas se gourer donc
ça fait plusieurs schémas retenir très
différents Laurent bon tu as l'habitude
sur ce genre de choses je pense que
c'est pas ouais c'est pas si non c'est
pas évident c'est pas évident parce
qu'il y a toujours des petites idées il
y a pas les mains vides
j'ai pas compris ta question c'est ce
qu'on va faire alors c'est quoi le plus
difficile pour toi entre championnat de
France 15 9 rondes que ça veut dire 15
fois 15 j'ai pas compris
à Dortmund de ma vie donc
j'ai parlé la question ce que je n'ai
pas compris je me suis si Laurent la
voix bah il va comprendre et je vois que
Chester doit fêter le vendredi soir
avant l'heure voilà
et tu sais il s'était mis le chat que
pour lui au départ
je vais me faire le chat pourra tout
seul j'ai mes petites questions pas sûr
qu'il les comprennent mais on va quand
même on va quand même les poser
Dortmund 2014 mais tu peux nous tu peux
nous expliquer la référence Dortmund
2014 mon cher chez som à faire
tu as fait un petit essai de questions
et chat GPT mais c'est pas très
concluant
et il est complètement il est à l'apé je
savais pas qu'il breton non il est
alsacien
il est pas l'apéro quand même on est
vendredi 17h remarque j'en aurais il
doit être à l'apéro
[Musique]
et il se défend sur ce sujet de l'apéro
c'est pas un sujet avec lequel il rigole
et salut à toi de people
donc qu'est-ce qu'on en pense de cette
position
j'aime pas ce qu'il a fait Christopher
parce que là avec son roi ici comment on
fait on va bouger le four
donc c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
pour les blancs qui ont trois pièces
mineures qui peuvent aller sur les cases
blanches tout à fait ouh là ça ça sent
la méthode ça ah bah c'est juste la base
du jeu de couleur mais effectivement
yoshif Dortmund l'explique très bien
mais c'est ça c'est vraiment pas
vulgariser je pense pour n'importe quel
joueur amateur et quand vous avez le
Food distinctif donc il y a un seul food
distinctif le fou B6 qui n'a pas de
vis-à-vis il y a pas de de foot case
noire chez les Blancs bah on devrait
ouvrir les cases noires sauf que c'est
pas possible le fou B6 pour l'instant il
n'a pas de perspective donc c'est
quelque chose de dynamique exactement
parce que le bilan statique est pas
terrible pour pour les noirs avec cette
structure de pion délicate ce roi qui
est faible et donc voilà c'est toute la
méthode de yossif c'est quand vous avez
un sur le long terme quand c'est pas
terrible sur le long terme et bien il
faut que faire quelque chose de
dynamique qu'est-ce que c'est quelque
chose de dynamique c'est un échange une
prise d'initiative forte ou alors un
changement de la structure de pion et
donc présiative Ford chawapa un échange
il sera pas terrible cet échange par
contre
ce F5 F4 ça pourrait être une prise
initiative qui ouvrira les cases noires
[Musique]
24 vous pouvez aller voir et peut-être
on aurait peut-être une surprise
peut-être une surprise sur cheeseccov
évidemment donc voilà on verra
intéressant pour donner des points de
repère voilà effectuer le bilan pour
pour les joueurs amateurs c'est très
intéressant
et en fait ce qu'il a fait la foule des
cinq rois B8
rigolo
C8 peut-être tu crois ou B6
pour commencer c'est pas grave il va
donner il va essayer de rebondir sur les
cases blanches
j'adore
et si tu étais pion tu sais que tu
rigoles tu dirais de jouer dynamique
donc Christopher finalement il suffit la
méthode ouais
s'il fait c'est un coup dynamique
aussi alors ça suffit pas que ça soit un
coup dynamique aussi que ça perd pas
toute la maison modéré le budget
sur le pion G2 c'est assez logique donc
il se met en relation avec ça c'est pas
donc là la méthode mais il avait F5 F4
salut à toi résonne
salut rezane salut à tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent
87 après ça dépend de ton niveau parce
que c'est vrai c'est ce que quand
il est bon raisin c'est 2000-200 mais le
truc c'est qu'il est très tacticien et
lui il connaît pas la méthode je peux te
dire non mais en fait la méthode souvent
la plupart des joueurs confirmés comme
réserve je ne connais pas je suis sûr
que c'est un joueur confirmé si tu le
dis et bien on l'applique en fait dans
le savoir donc c'est bien de verbaliser
ce genre de choses pour les joueurs un
tout petit peu plus modeste voilà je
dirais de de 1200 à 1800 après on
l'applique je pense qu'on l'applique
naturellement bien sûr tout à fait
raison c'est des points de repère pour
les les joueurs plus faibles voilà que
que les joueurs d'élite à partir de 2200
j'ai dit c'est les joueurs d'élite tu
vois 2200
Magnus mais pour les joueurs de club
pour moi c'est le joueur
bien sûr un peu toi tu te mets combien
[Musique]
départementale quoi tu vois donc c'est
pas 1002003 ah bon mais 2003 ah ouais
non mais c'est trop dur enfin je veux
dire 2003 ah d'accord ah par contre au
club a 1000 2003 bah ça reste je suis
bien au club là-bas au club
dans un gros club l'orange je jouais
dans la 7e équipe du club et la dernière
équipe du club et là dans mon petit club
de village bah je suis dans l'équipe
première quoi tu vois et c'est assez
industritable mais ça dépend de bah
voilà il y a les Asos de base et les
clubs de Bad comme il y a des petits
clubs d'échecs dans les bistrots on va
dire tout à fait
champion
c'est pas mal
alors d'abord
on est bien aussi on est d'accord c'est
bien c'est important d'avoir une bonne
ambiance très très bonne ambiance
alors dame B4 rencontres attaque ici
mais ça va être un peu léger contre
Arjun avec ce roi
ce roi qui fait peur cette structure de
pion qui est pas terrible on peut
imaginer un cavalier E4 hein pour un
cavalier bondissant peut-être un peu
plus pas mal pour l'instant à s'exprimer
à cause de Tours C8 voilà c'est le seul
truc que la paire de fou arrive à bien
gérer pour l'instant c'est les cavaliers
blancs du coup c'est pas facile encore
un peu compliqué
tous mes pions c'était peut-être pas
super
dans la typiquement il aime bien
calculer juste et on disait ça
l'acrobate pour Souf et j'aime bien
cette petite expression ça le définit
bien regali il adore bouffer les pions
alors est-ce qu'il va les laisser
facilement non mais voilà en fait c'est
ça coup statique on défend nos pions et
comme ça surtout C8 j'ai dame 4
je sais pas moi c'est ce que je ferais
mais bon c'est pas hyper inspiré disons
ni aspire mais elle est pas si facile
que ça je trouve la position blanche
à manipuler parce qu'elle est très
déséquilibrée les Noirs ont été malins
tout à l'heure la position était pas
facile à appréhender et maintenant
Laurent ils ont réussi à créer du jeu
c'est compliqué bon on va voir si
Eric Easy est un bon manipulateur de
position surtout C8 il veut jouer dans
le 7 ok ouais tu as raison en fait il
fait pas il fait pas crédi hein notre
ami Arthur très très bon joueur et on va
voir peut-être allez on n'a pas fait le
tour chez hadyban et Sabine info il sort
alors là c'est le c'est déséquilibré sur
le sur le papier comme un peu tout est
parti de Sabina aujourd'hui
ça va être compliqué qui me demande quel
classement en bas du coup donc je suis
D9 partout meilleur classement que j'ai
obtenu c'était D7 et c'était il y a il y
a un petit moment
fin de carrière fin de carrière fin de
carrière pour le bad
très dure que Laurent on démarre la
compétition pour moi je crois pas non
c'est trop dur à voir tes impressions je
refuse 9 fois sur 10 de jouer en simple
mais je préfère le double tu vois enfin
bien sûr le simple c'est trop dur oui
bah je partage ton avis
sache que dans les matchs par équipe il
y a que deux simples donc moi je suis
bon 3 ou 4e donc c'est bon j'en fais
aucun sauf que bah là
spécialiste double mais la problématique
c'est quand les Laurent les les deux
joueurs qui font les femmes n'étaient
pas là tout à fait simple donc j'ai fait
les simples là j'ai fait le simple j'ai
perdu en 3,7 d'ailleurs mais je joue un
mec bon je pensais même pas lui tirer un
set quoi c'était un jouable voilà donc
c'est très dur par soirée j'ai gagné le
double homme avec mon collègue qui fait
ça l'essentiel voilà
est-ce que comment on fait pas mal bravo
bravo 18 au bac au badminton d'accord
bravo comment on fait là B5 c'est 5
oulala ça s'appuf fois 3 ça ou le C4 qui
ouvre tout voilà Sabina
ça serait ça aurait du sens par rapport
à ce qu'on a dit j'ai l'impression que
X3 d'abord et ensuite c'est 4 et la
bonne chance il faut baisses ici à 5 ça
va pas B6 alors la C4
ça crie ça crie pour le C4 parce que
attention il y a la tour derrière donc
on peut pas prendre on peut pas prendre
faire exploser le centre
dans tous les écoles là il va toutes les
15 ans
il peut prendre il peut prendre il peut
tout bouffer
en force il y a G6 qui est menacé en
plus enfin c'est la galère ouais non ça
ne va pas du tout pour Sabina alors sur
quoi tu veux tu veux revenir peut-être
gauche Google est-ce que vous cache fait
mal assez assez compatriotes ou pas ça a
l'air d'aller pour gauche
avec les Noirs c'est un peu c'est un peu
étonnant d'ailleurs
parce que tellement vous cache
vous pouvez s'attendre à ce qu'il gagne
tout ça va
et il a peu de moi sur quel est français
cette tour C8 donc ça on peut pas
tourner deux pardon clouage donc on peut
pas le faire a priori on va prendre
et tourbé 2
en cas de prise en baisse
et oui j'ai pas tout reprend F8 dans de
bonnes conditions dommage alors la
finale de pion serait délicate avec ce
pion passé
comment je fais dans cette situation
pour pour gérer la problématique on va
le voir parce que ton français cette a
été joué tombé de a été joué évidemment
et maintenant il y a un léger souci
pour B7 surtout prends il va faire il va
faire ça il va faire le malin cavalier
aussi en menace tourbé 8 tu peux pas
sortir le roi si tu sors le fou je
prends le pion
alors on va voir kizako avec be stream
partout ils ont perdu au bled
avec plusieurs il a fallu qu'il se fasse
d'être il s'est passé des trucs
incroyables notamment un 2-0 inches
contre alors je veux pas du tout
stigmatiser Maxime c'est pas du tout
c'est la faute de l'équipe mais c'est
vrai que c'est le résultat auquel tu
t'attends pas quoi ouais bien sûr il y a
une rapide d'abord il se prend une bulle
oblique il se reprend une bulle c'est
vrai que bon on l'a pas vu venir le 2-0
contre Maxime
mais match ouais qui était qui s'est
joué sur rien si ça joue à après après
16 rapides si ça se joue au Blitz bon ça
veut dire que
tout le monde peut gagner
bon il est rentré dans une finale de
tour qui est nul
difficile non c'est nul
c'est nul c'est nul facile non en fait
je bouge pas je G6 3 G7 tu fais comment
je peux pas passer tu passes pas tu vas
être obligé d'échanger ce pion j'aurais
plutôt fait G6 moi parce que là il faut
faire attention à pas perdre tu vois
ça doit aller c'est ça
pardon il le jouera après de toute façon
G6 enfin dès que tu prends en C5 je peux
jouer G6 si je voulais ouais
ça va pas passer non on peut même
commencer à s'amuser à faire des échecs
et revenir dans les forages 7
attention à tourber 8 qui va menacer B7
et tour et fuite parce que si on perce
le pion ça peut être ça peut être gênant
il fait B7 ok sirop H7 maintenant c'est
une gaffe
attends mais tu joues quoi après
change pas
bon
G8 toujours pareil exactement
en 7e rangée on va C3 roi G6 jouer roi
des trois rois F7 et tout rage 8 ouais
mais j'aime pas ce qu'il a fait il a
donné des chances tu vois je vois pas G6
il a fait il a donné tout à 8
ok peut-être que
au moins on a créé un déséquilibre avec
les Blancs c'est vrai
j'aurais pu verrouiller encore plus ça
doit rester nul et on a
une très très bonne nouvelle pour pour
l'équipe indienne puisque
alors ça c'est assez surprenant c'est
vrai qu'on avait raté le milieu de jeu
mais bon écoute
Laurent ça va faire mal ouh là là il y a
trois points trois points là qui sont
arrivés en s'y attendait
la joueuse hein finalement qui peut
faire la différence comme dans tous ces
matchs dès qu'il y a dès qu'il y a une
joueuse qui qui marque des points
en général ça fait très très mal et qui
passe
on devrait tout doucement glissé vers un
match nul
parce que c'est dur pour les blancs de
créer quelque chose avec ce pion C2 qui
est quand même là en contre-pouvoir fort
contre-pouvoir
c'est bien ça te plaît non tu aimes bien
les petits expressions tu nous l'as dit
tout à l'heure ça t'a plu
comment tu fais
le c'est le coup bon
si je jouais on va le voir puis on prend
les deux et il va il va revenir on sait
que c'est les pions F et H c'est pas
c'est pas grand chose et surtout là
ils sont quand même très avancés
maintenant ah non il y a toujours
et final de pion nul
OK
l'enfer pour une licorne là qui va
devoir être fort 5,5
[Musique]
c'est pas impossible qui viennent de qui
viennent de la chaîne le match là
alors après il reste quand même au moral
on est qu'à la moitié du du match donc
peut se passer quand même le 3-0 là il
fait du mal il va falloir revenir
maintenant ils ont enfin ils ont utilisé
quasiment deux jokers alors là dessus
ils ont utilisé le
problème c'est que nijnic normalement
devait battre Arika
au prochain tour le match est quasiment
plié bien sûr bien sûr donc il va
falloir maintenant faire
faire très fort et ils ont quand même le
problème de
[Musique]
de la fin on sait que la féminine est
beaucoup plus faible dans l'équipe de
gookage l'équipe américaine donc du coup
ça va être compliqué quand même de se
refaire
le suspense
je suis désolé
[Rires]
d'être honnête exactement alors
je vais faire un petit tour j'ai
l'impression j'ai fait un petit tour sur
YouTube
donc là vous voyez on a la mi-temps du
du match et
les California se font bouger par
l'équipe indienne avec
Google je sais pas qui est marrant pour
l'équipe américaine
emmené parkaski lui-même indien belle
tête d'affiche mais l'équipe indienne
est très très forte avec une grand
maître mixte qui ferme
le quatrième échiquier ferme l'équipe
fait
il y a du dur parce qu'il y a Erica easy
qui l'emmène aussi donc c'est à peu près
égal avec Google
donc équipe très très homogène chez chez
les Indiens et très très forte voilà ils
sont bien
en tout cas alors bonne entrée en
matière il prendra une grosse option
pour la calife on rappelle qu'on se
retrouve évidemment la semaine prochaine
alors il y a certaines équipes comme je
vous l'ai dit qui ne vont pas jouer la
semaine prochaine comme les yogis d'un
dossier et les Gotham Knights mais aussi
les les Charlots Cobra et le perdant de
des joueurs de Berlin face à Saint-Louis
mais pour le reste ça joue et ça joue
gros parce qu'on voit les chaises bras
qui sont bien placés ils ont deux
victoires l'équipe de manuscrite of
aussi les shanghaystes les Tiger de
Shanghai aussi les normes
les boules dogs sont bien placés ils ont
ils doivent gagner un match sur deux
tandis que certaines équipes pardon
complètement
certaines équipes comme Blitz devront
gagner leur 2 derniers matchs forcer
et ça ça va pas être facile mais c'est
possible évidemment complètement en tout
cas les Indiens vont très bien Franky
qui vient d'arriver les Indiens ils sont
il y a eu deux premières premiers matchs
et sur le deuxième match bah là les
Indiens ont écrasé l'équipe américaine 3
et demi 0,5 c'est très cher avec le seul
nul obtenu par le joueur indien
justement de l'équipe américaine mais
qui était grand favori donc c'est pas
une bonne affaire
tout à fait
n'hésitez pas à évidemment à suivre à
nous suivre ou que vous soyez sur
YouTube sur twitch vous pouvez nous
suivre comme ça ce qui est bien si vous
êtes notifié à chaque fois qu'il y a un
show qui commence et donc vous pouvez
décider je regarde je regarde pas ça
nous aide aussi évidemment ça nous aide
à créer une communauté toujours plus
nombreuse et à vous offrir encore plus
de contenu à suivre beaucoup de tournois
que ça soit en line live voilà il y a
bientôt une coupe du monde par exemple
qui arrive
voilà ça sera ça sera très beau à suivre
il y a évidemment les tournois qui
arrivent de du champion de chaise tour
qui vont qui vont pas tarder à revenir
là je crois qu'il y en a un
début avril il y a qualifyer en mars
enfin énormément de choses qui se
passent toujours sur
un événement qu'on a vraiment après
cette commande
chasse d'ailleurs Laurence avait été
super sympa je perds de randoms à
commenter
si tu veux j'ai pas une grosse secteur
j'ai joué quand j'étais jeune tu vois
quelques petits tournois et à commenter
c'était hyper sympa ouais c'est bah
c'était hyper créatif c'était hyper
intéressant de voir la réactivité des
joueurs et ce qui faisait dans les
ouvertures hyper intéressant
et mais pas trop parce que
la position de départ est suffisamment
compliquée tu vois il y a pas besoin
d'en rajouter et donc c'est vrai qu'on a
un peu de mal à suivre pour être très
honnêtement un commentaire moi je
regardais ça vraiment en tant que
passionné et prouver que c'était en plus
la crème de la crème etc et du coup on
se on se régalait avec les parties ouais
vraiment top les concepts étaient très
élaborés
alors qu'est-ce que ça va donner au
niveau des appareils manquez il va jouer
il faut qu'il gagne absolument il compte
sur Google
les californiens
et Christopher you aussi qui a zéro sur
deux Sabina foyers sur deux va falloir
commencer à débloquer tout ça parce que
sinon il va tourner course ce match et
ça sera comme hier on n'aura pas de
quatrième set et en plus faudrait pas
faire de partout tu vois parce que de
partout ça sera un 4e 7 un petit peu
ça va être mais ça va être dur donc
attends tu as dit donc on a pareillement
je pense qu'on a goûté je contrôle
pas ensuite on aura
Erik easy
contre qui non non ça sera non c'est
goocache mascarade plutôt
Google mascara
tu m'aurais pas fait un appareil man
dans la même équipe là Laurent pour
essayer de me piéger goûter
j'en sais rien et toi tu en sais rien en
plus je sais et
Erik easy niznik
jouera Arika et sabinafisor jouera
gauche et la faune explose de Sabina
mais ça j'y crois pas trop gauche il
vient de faire nul Kesh ça fait du bien
au moral
pour les pour les Américains là
clairement ils sont dans le dur en fait
ouais il y a trois matchs équilibrés et
un où ils sont quasiment foutus quoi
donc
d'où l'importance de la joueuse forte ça
c'est exactement ça change tout
qui a commencé qui avait tenu que ça
fait un écart ça donne tout de suite ça
met tout de suite les Américains dans
une situation archi délicate
c'est vraiment très très important
alors je suppose qu'ils vont bientôt
commencer il y a des gros breaks
n'hésitez pas
à l'air comme on dirait-je d'être hyper
inquiet donc ça pas ça doit pas être
commencé
non il se lève tellement il est pas
inquiet
je sais pas combien il y a de breaks
exactement c'est vrai qu'en général on
en profite pour faire un break bon là
c'est un peu tard ça va bientôt
commencer exactement
mais
voilà on va voir donc les prochains
matchs je crois auront lieu
auront lieu mercredi ou peut-être mardi
je sais pas parce que en moins de match
évidemment avec quatre équipes soit deux
équipes qualifiées deux équipes
éliminées
et bien mine de rien ça fait quatre
équipes en moins qui joue et donc ça
nous fait plus que 6 matchs au lieu de
au lieu de 8
je demandais d'ailleurs
quand avait lieu les matchs à Nathan
pour savoir un petit peu il me dit ah
c'est pas encore tiré donc là ça vient
d'être tiré je crois Laurent
pas encore ça dépend des résultats de ce
soir aussi tu vois d'accord et les
équipes un truc qui arrange plus ou
moins parce qu'évidemment c'est streamé
c'est ça exactement qui a tous les
joueurs donc on essaie d'arranger tout
le monde dans la mesure du possible donc
c'est du truc vous voyez c'est on essaie
de faire un truc possible
en argent tout le monde mais voilà en
tenant compte des aspirations enfin des
sweats alors je veux dire en général ça
c'est une c'est un truc organisé moi
j'ai moi qui est à ma petite échelle des
j'ai essayé d'organiser en fait j'ai
organisé des tu te rappelles on avait
cette menteur Blitz Cup avec 128 joueurs
donc fallait j'en ai contacté des
joueurs
tu vois deux joueurs pour fixer une
heure tu vois une heure qui est du sens
pour nous et puis alors je te raconte
pas machin mercredi après-midi j'ai
piscine l'autre il est pas content et
puis il dit après l'autre il t'envoie un
message privé en disant mais pourquoi tu
dis oui à tout à l'autre tu vois ça
comme le match a déjà commencé enfin bon
c'est l'enfer
après il y a des gens sympas aussi mais
la plus souvent c'est
quand même pas ça
donc là je sais pas comment ils font
exactement mais ça a l'air de bien se
passer en tout cas
et puis il faut voir les appareils on va
voir contre qui joue
au moins il y a des effectifs larges qui
permettent quand même aux équipes d'être
bien représentées qui a pas de trou etc
ça le fait quoi ouais mais là tu vois
par exemple il y a champion d'Europe qui
a commencé d'ailleurs on souhaite
je crois tu vas te joindre à moi tu
souhaites pas bonne chance toi ah si si
je souhaite bonne chance
particulièrement je pense à Jules
Moussard ce serait bien qu'il aille loin
dans le film Lagarde et d'autres
Français en tout cas ces trois-là sont
destinés à jouer les les premiers rôles
aux Championnat d'Europe donc on leur
souhaite le meilleur ils ont commencé à
jouer aujourd'hui et voilà typiquement
Étienne Macron ne pourra pas jouer pour
Blitz la semaine prochaine même s'il est
pas joué les deux premières semaines
aussi mais en fait ça fait une petite
option en moins bien sûr allez on doit
pas être loin de
les compteurs sont remis à zéro en tout
cas d'accord on va pouvoir repartir
est-ce que ça va être le dernier match
on sait pas
c'est la première fois que je te vois un
petit côté Jean-Pierre Bacri un petit
côté Jean-Pierre
là
naissante ou pas d'ailleurs la calvitie
mais en tout cas si elle est naissante
c'est depuis un petit moment quand même
donc elle ne serait pas naissante du
coup
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire quoi MGD
1 mais c'est le quiz
l'orange je vais te laisser répondre à
cette évident
c'est le quiz du jour allez-y
si vous croyez alors déjà Kévin il en a
absolument aucune idée moi j'aurais pu
avoir une idée un peu plus que Kévin
parce que je prépare c'est chaud quand
même avec beaucoup plus de
professionnalisme
de
à savoir ce que ça veut dire
un max doudou ou McDo slow comme
l'appelle stouf il y a quoi à gagner il
y a notre notre considération à gagner
et quand même il cherche pas il a posé
la question il est plein c'est la
politique du moindre effort demande à
GPT demandez
cette histoire qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette époque où on cherche plus rien
laisse tomber ça vaut pas le coup
quoi notre considération
tu as marqué les esprits avec avec tes
goodies Laurent j'avais plein en plus
dans la chez moi dans mon petit truc
j'attends des sorties c'est comme le bon
vin tu es sur 10 ans plus tard
[Musique]
je sais pas je sais pas
bonjour fait plaisir
il fait référence alors ça a commencé ça
a commencé on a on a hadyban contre
Google ça sera une partie très très
importante il y a 10 panne qui peut tout
envoyer il peut le battre Google
attention
ça serait la fin
la fin de quoi
pour l'équipe vous cache il est en mast
win quasiment si Google ne gagne pas
Laurent pour ton petit 3
non c'est fait
mais je comptais les Indiens moi
pardon donc MLF 3 qu'est-ce qui va nous
faire goûter s'il faut qu'il joue
remarque il y a pas besoin il y a pas
besoin en fait il y a pas besoin d'aller
le chercher à divan normalement il s'en
va en l'air tout seul
il y a pas de problème avec ça
s'il fait nul c'est un super résultat
pour sa team donc il va peut-être être
un peu plus tranquille par exemple sur
la ragozine c'est vrai qu'il y a des
ventes forcée de nul que hadibad va
connaître et laragosine c'est vraiment
le répertoire de boukh ce qui joue en
partie longue mais il est bloqué
d'ailleurs je vous cache là ouais parce
qu'il se dit faut qu'il joue autre chose
en fait
même s'il est pas sûr évidemment que
Hannibal ira pour la nul
mais il faut quand même c'est marrant là
la petite situation vous voyez que dans
le match vous cash il est obligé de
gagner avec les noirs et c'est pas
facile
donc il se pose les questions exactement
on va voir nijnic contre
irigaty c'est vrai que sur le papier
petit petit début de Londres
une de ces nombreuses
début de Londres on a vu tout à l'heure
la trompe-ovski on a parlé du début
jobava il joue tous les sous-systèmes
qui sont peu théoriques mais il les
connaît très très très très bien
alors
vous êtes cavalier au 5 et 17 fous des
trois rock damage 5 et F5 et il va tout
envoyer égaliser ou pas il envoie
c'est le grand classique de ces
positions on ferme le centre pour
pouvoir attaquer
il a fait d'abord qui prend des sets
et il va faire G4 à mon avis
peut-être ou même cavalier F6 suite key
prend le 5 et qui est pro G4 ça pourrait
faire mal donc il fait ça
et réfléchi pour la forme mais remarque
un valf 3 est pas mal aussi on a quand
même créé un affaiblissement sur case
noire
forcément on voit qu'il aime bien
balancer ça c'est logique est-ce que sur
G4 est-ce que j'ai le droit de faire G6
Laurent et de prendre en G4 en force
on va le montrer et ça permet une pièce
j'ai 4 a été joué maintenant il a pas
joué G6 certainement dommage 6 ouais
c'est ça je regardais ça et on peut
surpris G4 il y a plein de
complications
jouer par ouais c'est typique comme dans
les Français tu sais où tu fais
ressortir ce fou de l'autre côté dans
toutes ces structures ou le Fou est
vraiment mauvais ben on l'amène sur la
diagonale pour le rendre moins mauvais
donc tu as été obligé d'échanger et
réghaïsi et compte peut-être sur
l'attaque sur la colonne g pour faire la
différence
en fait il est obligé maintenant d'y
compter
ce qu'il a quand même fait de sérieuses
affaiblissement alors c'est bien sympa
ce G4 et tout ça mais du coup tu peux
plus trop tu peux toujours ok ici mais
il y a quand même du contre jeu il y
aura ses points des quatre qui va
arriver donc en rock est compliqué
il faut vraiment jouer l'équilibre ici
mais c'était sans doute un peu prématuré
mais c'est tellement le style des regga
easy de jouer comme ça très calculatoire
compliqué là c'est toujours le bordel
cette position très déséquilibrée
est-ce qu'on joue avec grand rock pour
G1 et c'est le bazar complet
il y a pas trop le choix bon pas
terrible pour l'équipe mais c'est son
style et reggaeysie va pas
alors est-ce qu'on y croit tu croyez pas
oh non elle est blanche
trajet
on va montrer on va montrer jolie c'est
une combinette
c'est vraiment une combinette on voit
avec ce vis-à-vis un âme c'est cette
elle fait de la meuf 3 et là c'est une
énorme gaffe parce qu'elle C4 pourquoi
ça va pas parce que si on prend du
carton que j'aime bien
et ben elle a fait une gaffe en un cours
regardez c'est très très mignon
et donc très très dur et le problème de
ces quatre c'est si on recule et bien
c'est la fourchette
et donc elle a fait quoi elle a fait
qu'il prend des 7 mais je crois qu'elle
perd du matériel quand même
ça change pas le problème
je prends tu prends et plus précis et
Laurent pour justement éviter ce truc là
et avoir un autre truc dis-moi tu as
passé trois
merci
on est là on est pas très bien on est
d'accord mais on n'est pas
avec une pièce de moins parce qu'une
pièce de moins c'est ça
elle a trouvé mais ça lui a coûté du
temps et de coup gauche il essaie de
trouver encore mieux mais c'est de voir
s'il peut pas gagner la pièce mais il y
a pas ça ça le miracle de mini miracle
pour Sabina Foisor ouais qui a eu un peu
de bol là sur ce coup parce qu'elle a
pas vu venir le truc ça c'est à peu près
sûr c'est trois tu prends la barre
et OK
donc
qui prend des 7 y réfléchit ça peut pas
ça pour pour l'inverse mais bon ça reste
quand même très très raisonnable cette
position c'est pour ça qu'il réfléchi
d'ailleurs puisqu'il se dit qu'il a
failli gagner tout de suite et du coup
il peut gamer un petit peu
et Christopher you qui sera aussi avec
les blancs dans une situation de
victoire impérative il faut appeler un
chat
tout simplement
un début début agréable en tout cas pour
Christophe
il a fermé le centre
d'échange quelque chose comme ça
une slave un gamme à la Carsen donc elle
est cassis c'est là c'est 5 le petit
coup B6 et maintenant on prend et c'est
vrai que ça ressemble à une slave
d'échange bon ça reste toujours comme le
savent des changes en général c'est un
petit peu plus agréable pour les blancs
mais si les Noirs savent ce qu'ils font
celle-là donc du coup bon il va en
baisser
c'est pas mal ce qu'il a fait avec enfin
c'est connu de toute façon de jouer pour
F4
et
facile et puis ça évite tous les thèmes
cavaliers 4 pour se faire museler le fou
des trois c'est ça c'est vrai donc
clairement
le vent
elle pourrait après refaire F5 pour
essayer de fermer la poésie Laurent
peut-être la poésie ouais
la Poste tu dis toi la position
[Rires]
alors faut prendre environ ouais c'est
ça et maintenant c'est vrai que si on
prend ici on a on a rétabli la structure
et les noirs sont très bien et la peur
de fou en plus c'est moi qui ai la
colonne ouverte donc il a pas fait ça
bien évidemment il a joué G4 elle fait
F5 Harry k alors évidemment on a envie
est-ce qu'on peut s'infiltrer c'est ce
qui fait roi G7 il va faire damage 5 et
ensuite il va faire G4
à un moment bon
la poésie la première fois j'entends ça
mais bon tu m'apprends des trucs mais en
général c'est pas c'est pas hyper
décisif dans ma vie tu vois
et voilà faut prendre F5 c'était un des
thèmes après ce que ça marche encore
mais bon ça a l'air sympa à jouer ça a
l'air tu sais quoi
ça a l'air super sympa j'ai pas vu qu'on
l'a jauge s'excite pas
sur 3 je crois
c'est ça ah non j'ai cru j'ai
systématique
3 si je fais
cavalier revient le même ça ouais là
c'est
il y a déjà beaucoup de pions même d'un
prof 7 fait mal c'est beaucoup de monde
ça ne va pas du tout
de grosse boulette parce que c'était
mon idée j'espère que tu tombes dans le
piège ouais je me suis pris tu as vu
quand même
donc du coup je montre et on ramasse la
dame je l'ai dit pour l'exemple
non
on va revenir
donc on prend intéressant de cette
partie en tout cas et elle pourrait
relancer un petit peu les Américains
en pratique c'est tellement dur à jouer
pour les Noirs quasi impossible
doit faire l'exploit contre iriga easy
c'est comme ça et c'était pas si mal
parti sur ce qu'on voit
bon ok rien de fait
mais
Yu font des bonnes parties donc ça
pourrait
relancer un tout petit peu le match en
cas de victoire de boukesh et s'il
confirme ça c'est pas sûr allez on va
voir Google
il a dû oublier un moment le fousser
deux qui a l'air vraiment très très
embêtant avec la dame à un colorant nous
montre en rouge
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il a
fait finalement kbd7 il a pas fait
saragosine on a eu un gamin très très
solide
très connue
un petit plus sans risque et il a été
mettre sa dame
en B1 et ses prix un thème je pense
qu'il a spéculé l'orange sur la
structure d'option il avait vu cavalier
prend F6 et je t'ai dit que ça allait
mais même si je vois pas trop
en fait la dame garde le contrôle donc
on reprend exactement c'est joli
puis on prend on voit qu'il a il a cru
que la structure allait être endommagée
en fait le fou c'est deux est super
pénible quoi c'est pas facile c'est pas
son style notre ami après c'est pas fini
fouder un très bon coup il essaie
d'enlever le problème
ouais mais il va perdre
je le vois Père Noël
ça fait deux points déjà peut-être
peut-être à erikasing je pense que c'est
la partie clé annule
ok bon bah c'est pas si mal finalement
pour les deux et demi tu peux avoir ton
dos et demi bon il faut juste vérifier
que gauche fait bien le travail contre
Sabine à foisard donc ça
il a joué ça quand même ouh là là elle
prend l'eau
elle se bat ça se bat ça se bâche et
Sabina mais est-ce qu'on y croit en
difficulté quand même vous voyez il y en
a moins d'espace elle est plus coincée
le foot casse blanche peut se réactiver
c'est un peu plus délicat pour elle mais
c'est pas encore fini elle est mal au
temps aussi ah c'est un enfer
chez Sabina donc il faut vraiment que
Christophe for you confirme contre
arrêta et
il faut pas qu'elle dit banne tienne
contre bouquet pour que ça se passe bien
pour les Américains qui font un meilleur
match
de très loin c'est terminé
il y a pas photo là quand même dans ce
dans ce match c'est une évidence pour
l'instant en tout cas
bon cette partie elle a l'air ouais on
la compte pas faut deux victoires et ça
ferait combien ça ferait 7 7 5 le
dernier match pourquoi pas cette 5 ça
pourrait jouer
on va voir si Erika qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé cher Ikea c'est vraiment décisif
est-ce que Christopher you a réussi à
passer ah c'est avant de condamner
la parole aussi à
beaucoup de pions ça a l'air quand même
très très bien pour les blancs
cela en termes de temps aussi
après
mais le fou le fou B7 il tire mort il
est
vraiment pas bien placé très mauvaise
pièce
alors cavalier FC elle se bat il y a
quand même pions c'est un peu
casse-gueule comme position Laurent faut
faire gaffe à sa place
trois pions c'est trop
trois pions
en C8
mais il y a beaucoup beaucoup de pions
comme nous le dit Laurent
et du coup mes pièces ont du mal à
s'activer là ça y est ce que je fais
comme comme coup si la partie d'ailleurs
trop dur d'échanger
après
ça a été joué
l'attaque sur le roi noir le roi Nord
plus fragile
et en manque d'idées ici avec les noirs
c'est une cata tout simplement
est-ce qu'on pourrait voir gokash
c'est comme si c'était fait super merci
Laurent
tu veux voir les caméras je suppose
aussi ah bah évidemment évidemment
et
c'est un tout petit peu un chouillard
tourné par rapport à tout à l'heure ou
c'est les noirs qui dominaient on va
peut-être assister à un match nul parce
que les blancs sont vraiment activés
Laurent
en fait match nul c'est au nord de
prouvé le match nul on vient de perdre
un pion il s'est passé qu'est-ce qu'il a
qu'est-ce qu'il y a trafiqué là Google
c'est la cata alors là s'il est là
on peut assister quasiment une fin de
match attention quasiment
salut Florent
hello à tous ceux qui arrivent c'est une
catastrophe là ça se passe mal pour les
Américains non seulement ils sont ils
sont moins fort
mais ça se passe mal en plus
ouais et contre l'équipe indienne
il joue moins bien
et ouais c'est vrai qu'il en a gagné
hein des tournois déjà seulement 16 ans
pour pouvoir chambrer finalement Laurent
qu'on ne sait pas
il est quand même il est quand même fort
Google 16 ans
2718 et puis on le voit dans les
tournois là il vient de finir un tournoi
dissoldorf où il a quand même fini
premier execo invaincu avec aronyan
Guiri d'où ça torov ouais c'est les
sauts
il est moi je trouve avec Abdou satorov
c'est les deux alors
quatre mondial déjà mais en tout cas
c'est les deux Google
qui sont à mon sens les plus les plus
stables les plus impressionnants qui ne
déçoivent jamais
on va voir si elle dit bad gagne mais je
crois que il va gagner en vrai fermez-la
ça devient facile à jouer il se prend
tous les coups du tennis là Google
passons jour
ou alors peut-être qu'il a été envoyé
comme espion par les Indiens
super joueur il y a pas trop de raisons
qui cagoule son avantage non puis il y a
pas de pression par rapport au match tu
vois même si il perd c'est pas très
grave
il est cuit dur x 8
C4 aussi très intéressant
ouais mais ça va arriver
c'est quasiment certain menace tour à 7
menaces
qui à mon avis termine le travail ou
cavalier D6 encore plus forte
salut Élie phase
alors est-ce que
là
il va abandonner je pense et gauche a
bien battu Sabine à Foisor comme on s'y
attendait et donc il reste
c'est parti va permettre peut-être de
rester en vie tout simplement de faire
un match un peu pro du beurre parce que
ce sera pour un 4-0
avec Sabina qui a pris 3-0 qui jouera
contre dire que
sans qui jouera contre
ah oui ce sera le match pardon africain
oui oui ça a déjà été joué
il faudrait que ça tourne en 4-0 et puis
équilibré elle rend 300 points hello
quoi
déjà commençons par le commencement you
avec 5 minutes il doit battre à Rica il
est beau beaucoup mieux voire
complètement gagnant mais attention
voilà ce genre de position faut finir le
taf
c'est pas fait
un peu de travail c'est une position où
on peut se prendre les une tactique un
sale truc on le voit bien
il peut y avoir un oubli une fois qu'on
a plus que quelques secondes à Laurent
tout à fait c'est facile avait
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est qu'il est pas
hyper confiant si il joue aussi
lentement c'est que il y a des problèmes
à régler alors attention à ce pur qui
traîne quand même
[Musique]
pas mal
pour essayer d'embrouiller vous voyez
l'idée
par aryka qui vend charmant sa peau
regardez les résultats qui sont là deux
heures et demie ça fait 8 3 8 donc une
nul de Rica et c'est gagné une défaite
et on joue un quatrième match un peu
pour du beurre comme tu l'as dit mais
quand même
franchement c'est le temps quand tu nous
le dis comme ça non mais il y a 1% 2%
ça c'est jamais 0 non non c'est jamais 0
on sait jamais 0 Sabina Foisor pourrait
nous sortir le grand jeu Laurent
je connaissais pas comme ça en tant que
haters
[Rires]
[Musique]
en grande forme
pourquoi tu en parles au passé de
l'équipe stream Moget n'en parle pas au
passé elle est toujours et toujours dans
la compète il va falloir maintenant il y
a plus le droit à l'erreur et après tout
ça peut aller vite de toute façon c'est
des cadences 10 plus 2 vous voyez ça va
très très très très vite et attention à
Christopher you
il y a plus de temps donc il faut
ça peut merdouiller cette position même
si on voit que la jauge est très
clémente avec les Blancs ce qui est
normal
il y a toujours un léger espoir ah non
non non mon greffe à l'équipe de Blitz
peut encore gagner mais par contre faut
gagner les deux prochains matchs faut
gagner le quart de finale faut gagner à
demi-finale il faut gagner la finale ils
sont mal embarqués mais mais mauvais
début ça on va pas on va pas mentir mais
au début ça veut pas dire mauvaise fin
toujours pareil un ricard c'est bien
battu mais il a été très fort Christophe
are you pour l'instant même avec cette
10 secondes
les California du coup ils vont se
contenter d'un petit match
pour finir
alors pour prendre monastère G5 menace
un peu tout Rouen
parce qu'il a plus de temps on espère un
oubli
la tour première fois aussi sa tension
il faut jouer tourage si c'est à mon
avis
et sur ça
fait encore un pion
maintenant c'est l'autoroute des
vacances
fini
on va voir un dernier match pour notre
plaisir il y a du suspense regardez
Laurent il attend il est un peu
pour
respirer tu vois la pause parce que le
suspense c'est tellement grand
il faut prendre sa respiration donc on
va faire un petit break c'est un peu
stressé
en plus je les connais c'est tous des
super pote dans la équipe indienne
donc ils sont très sympa je connais pas
juste mais surtout bon garçon en fait
très sympa
[Musique]
la tête ouais tu as joué avec lui et
donc
franchement tous les Indiens ils sont
ils sont jeunes et hyper sympas ils se
prennent pas la tête aucune exigence
juste jouer tous les matchs je te dis
sur l'exigence
c'est sympa il parle et tout il rit à
tes blagues ou pas
est-ce qu'il rigole à tes blagues témoin
en anglais donc je peux pas transposer
ce que j'arrive à faire magnifiquement
en français il y a que de chasse comme à
faire tu vois et la zone France qui peut
profiter de de ces blagues enivrante
alors parce qu'en fait s'il avait
s'il a fait semblant de rigoler à tes
blagues là c'était vraiment la crème tu
vois ah j'arrive pas non non en anglais
je reste modeste tu sais bien ok
donc victoire de de roi prend il y a à
huit dames et donc comme vous le voyez à
l'écran il y a un petit problème de ça
c'est pas rafraîchir mais vous allez le
voir arriver il y a 8 4 voilà c'est ils
sont pas
donc il reste une nulle
d'arrêter ils ont cru qu'ils avaient
déjà perdu non non victoire de you non
non c'est Ricard en plus c'est l'équipe
gagnante ah ça serait bon qui partent
donc 8 4 nous ce qu'on fait c'est que il
y a une grosse tension là donc
grosse tension petit break
donc avec
petite musique choisie par petite
musique
petit cadeau pour la plateforme de cours
en ligne si ça vous intéresse vous
pouvez aller la découvrir voilà comme ça
vous êtes bien pendant la pause vas-y
explose à faire
tous les petits conseils de coach Kevin
très sympa avec les petits stages d'été
là pour grand pour moins grand toujours
super
voilà allez à tout de suite
à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes de retour pour ce match
palpitant entre les California unicornes
et les Indiens vont-ils tous craquer en
même temps on va voir le score mon cher
Kévin le score est de 8 à 4 j'y crois
pas trop hein je vous ai dit j'ai été
franc tu me fais une cote
honnêtement là on peut on peut envoyer
du mug dans tous les sens il y aura pas
de surprise
je sais pas on fait quoi on fait un
allez s'il est California unicornes
gagne
ce match
je donne un mug au premier qui va faire
un commentaire dans le chat allez je
l'envoie la poste et j'envoie il y a
zéro chance allez-y on va voir qui suit
j'ai qu'un seul mug je pouvais je
pouvais en faire un je pouvais doubler
la mise
Francky Finistère Morbihan
ça y est c'est gagné je veux
je pense que Bruno si tu avais
si tu avais fait un commentaire plus
court pu que tu pouvais jouer pour
gagner le mug mais honnêtement
bon on va aller mieux pas jouer hein
c'était c'était un piège c'était très
piégeux très facétieux de la part de
Laurent qui n'y croit pas lui-même
[Musique]
et oui ça arrive ça arrive on sait
jamais un réveil de beaucoup plus
probable que qu'une victoire des
California dans cette situation me
collecte-toi qui a déjà les enchères ont
déjà commencé à 40 euros quelle blague
et Bruno et vert et il dit mauvaise
stratégie c'est vrai Bruno tu avais joué
le jeu mais tu es pas récompensé en fait
tout simplement
alors les parties n'ont pas commencé
peut-être on va parler de tes de tes
cours et de tes stages donc c'est une
plateforme c'est ça
on a toujours le cadeau
il est toujours en ligne le cadeau on
peut toujours en profiter
le cadeau l'inscription à la plateforme
ça qui est pratique d'accord ok donc et
le cadeau justement c'est un peu le mode
erikesi c'est-à-dire je conseille un
petit peu les ouvertures que je trouve
adaptées aux amateurs voilà et du coup
pas mal de système dans dans les
propositions pour éviter de se prendre
trop la tête avec
avec les ouvertures tout simplement de
pas rentrer dans la gros jungle
théorique dès le départ pour pour les
moins confirmés d'entre vous c'est la
base de toute façon et après quand vous
avez un meilleur niveau tactique et
stratégique là vous pouvez aller plus
loin dans les ouvertures mais autant
j'aime bien avoir une petite coquille
d'ouverture Laurent avec un mini
répertoire simplifié mais je veux pas
que ça parte dans le délire de
connaissance théoriques
ultra importantes
évidemment ça a du sens ça laisse du
temps pour travailler la tactique ou les
finales ou
tout ce que peut nous offrir de
complexes le jeu d'échec exactement et
en parlant de complexité on va avoir un
gros cache à regaizy ma foi on est
content de voir ça c'est bien ça c'est
vraiment le grand format et ça démarre
d'ailleurs je crois qu'on va avec une
ouest pour réaliser
tout fois 6 plutôt fois 6 c'est en étant
c'est quand même la mode c'est jouer
et
très agressif
de
se connecter un sacrifice de pions sur
C5 sur ces 5 on fait des 5 on donne le
pion la grande mode et c'est très très
dangereux non on fait fou de cette
pardon d'abord parce que ça irait dans
le 4
juin
pour vous montrer la thématique mais
fou B7 et ensuite on va on donne ce pion
on ignore
avec la case F5 pour la dame
et il est casses blanches qui sont
affaiblies ce pion qui préférait le voir
en C7 des cavaliers
les pièces qui s'imbriquent bien chez
les Blancs belle harmonie de pièces
donc fouder 2 on va voir ce qu'il a fait
erikazy a pas l'air de
c'est ce qui choisit aussi
à arriver tu sais c'est supporter du PSG
ils sont tous on est tous traumatisés
par cette fameuse remonte à la
ce truc improbable qui arrive une fois
alors c'est ton jamais
il a pris il a joué ses cinq
prochainement il y aura déjà un gros
retour qu'on le Bayern d'ailleurs
Laurent ouh là là moi je sens bien j'ai
pas toi
très chauvant très chauvant donc du coup
[Musique]
avec un bon bapé ils vont la coller
j'ai pas cette remarqué mais ils ont
fait ça c'est marrant c'est marrant ils
ont fait ça le 14 février le match aller
donc le jour de la Saint-Valentin et le
retour et le 8 mars la Journée des
droits des femmes donc c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment c'est
ambiance joueur de foot
à peu près c'est je veux dire il y a
deux jours dans l'année tu vois où on
célèbre un petit peu
tu vois l'amour les femmes tu vois moi
c'est tous les jours avec moi mais
on demandera je demanderai je demanderai
la principale intéressée enfin la seule
intéressée pardon
c'est pas la principale la principale
c'est pas mal
ça va pas lui faire plaisir
si elle est cool j'espère qu'elle écoute
pas du coup
mais en tout cas la seule intéressée
unique unique à notre connaissance
évidemment
si c'est célébré tous les jours ou pas
désolé
alors comment on fait maintenant avec ce
pion
on peut prendre
l'ouverture pour l'instant c'est vrai
que ça va mais bon les blancs aussi bon
écoute celle-là on peut rester tourner
et aller voir peut-être les femmes
justement peut-être des femmes Laurent
directement et oui oui on va voir on va
voir on va voir puisqu'on en parler
c'est ça exactement
[Musique]
c'est le top 20 mondial voir top 15 2500
et là elle fait une ligne qui est
normalement pas terrible ce 5 très tôt
et le pion en C4 c'est Dame B3 ouais on
est obligé de jouer un coup qu'on a pas
envie de jouer comme dame C8 et
franchement ok je vais beaucoup de
Retiers avec les blancs
des trois est très intelligent on va
jouer pour se prendre des 5 à un moment
et peut-être 4 c'est ça ça dépend des 5
c'est 4 il y a tous ces thématiques là
pour aller ouvrir le roi E8 et sur
crander c'est prendre des c'est pas
logique du tout avec la dame en C8 tout
à fait on va pouvoir créer un vis-à-vis
donc déjà pour un joueur de rétine moi
qui ai joué pas mal de métiers avec les
Blancs c'est en gros c'est ce que tu
espères comme Max tu vois tu peux pas
faire mieux de l'ouverture alors après
ça reste loin c'est pas gagnant mais
effectivement
c'est c'est ce que tu espères en fait
tout simplement
mais voilà après c'est prend maintenant
il y a du kic-3 et au 4 qui va arriver
avec ce roi qui est là qui est mal placé
on peut même envisager des sacrifices
en plus
bon ok
c'est dur pour elle
n'a pas pour l'instant en fait dans ces
cadences là faut quand même des
pré-requis théorique fort elle les a pas
donc du coup ça part mal dès le début et
en plus elle est plus faible
comme ça effectivement
c'est dur mais c'est la vie c'est cette
compétition elle pardonne pas c'est
vraiment
c'est pas le même niveau à Rica c'est
vraiment une joueuse
de très très grande qualité grand maître
mixte et Sabina Foisor je sais pas elle
doit pas être pro mais elle était 2300
un moment Sabine à foison c'est pour ça
que c'est plutôt elle doit pas être au
meilleur moment on voit des joueurs qui
sont et joueuses plus ou moins investies
et là elle est pas forcément
au summum de son investissement donc du
coup ça fait sanctionner par des super
joueurs pour que là j'ai l'impression
qu'elle a réussi à trouver un petit truc
sur le papier ça peut être une bonne
recrue parce que tu dis elle est quand
même sous classée elle a eu beaucoup
plus donc tu peux te dire c'est pas mal
mais en fait elle est tellement pas
investie apparemment que
c'est tellement fort aussi en face c'est
pas de sa faute c'est que juste que le
plateau est ultra relevé quoi
et on voit 4 un cavaliers va bondir un
F5 à un moment ou un autre
et déjà des problèmes à résoudre pour
Sabina foyors qui pourrait mettre fin à
ce match en la Christopher you avec les
Noirs contre gauche ça écoute ça peut
jouer
elle est bien parce que elle peut être
dangereuse avec une une féminine aussi
forte dans l'équipe franchement
dangereuse
stream a battu lors de la première ronde
donc ça met en lumière l'exploit des
de l'équipe Blitz
parce que cette équipe c'est vrai qu'on
la voit bien se qualifier là quand même
est-ce qu'elle nous montre aujourd'hui
elle va pouvoir 2 sur 3 et donc toutes
les chances de se qualifier on a dit ban
aussi face à mijnic
faut avouer
mais
ça reste quand même mieux pour les
blancs non
sans doute vu la jauge mais bon avec le
roi G3 le pion F4 c'est un peu bizarre
comme ouais c'est pas un puromètre de
plus ça c'est sûr
ok bon c'est vrai que c'est pas si
facile d'en profiter et la dame pourra
revenir en C7
on va voir notre grand format allez
et ensuite je rentre ça peut-être et les
parties entre les féminines ça va se
jouer sur ça c'est la partie la plus
dure entre a gagné entre
entre Sabine info
cash qui a un petit position de travail
qui va peut-être amener les pions
pendant à Laurence ce genre de structure
et on va faire pression sur ce pion en
C5
directement le pion des 5 donc c'est
intéressant
oui alors si si tu veux son adresse oui
je me sens l'adresse mais alors on va
attendre quand même que ça soit finalisé
cette histoire on sait jamais il peut y
avoir peut-être
bon je sais que je vais l'envoyer mais
bon évidemment je prenais ton adresse
on va attendre un petit peu
trois C1 ok on menace de prendre
clairement et de d'encaisser un pion il
faut faire très attention avec les Noirs
est-ce qu'on pousse
est-ce qu'on fait un coup de cavalier B4
ça doit être les deux options
principales ici pour les noirs pour C8
aussi ouais alors ton C8 ça repose
certainement sur le fait que sur pions
il y a cavalier BE4 attaque la dame et
protège le pion
donc ça c'est pas mal
et
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec les Blancs
ici on va recule
je pensais
pas trop sur achat on sait jamais ça
peut être
titre
effectivement intéressant il a joué à 3
pour empêcher ce qu'est B4 et donc re
menacer de prendre
sur ça
et qui a l'air pas mal honnêtement
bonne activité de pièces pour compenser
le 32 à l'aile dame et les pions C5 à 7
même s'ils sont isolés ils sont
difficiles à toucher à Laurent tout à
fait
bon il y a pas grand chose si c'est
quelque chose c'est vraiment pas grand
chose
isolé pion arrière il faut qu'il soit
sur colonne semi-ouverte pour qu'on
puisse les taper avec les tours pour que
ça fasse mal
donc il y a un petit plus blanc mais
sans doute que c'est pas assez
quoi petit plus parce que justement il y
a cette pion c'est 5 à 7 la majorité
elle date mais il faudrait réussir à
changer il faudrait réussir à échanger
les pièces lourdes pour avoir des vraies
chances
de gain
de la colonne quand même mais pourquoi
pas
et pourquoi pas
surtout pas échanger le cavalier 5 qui
domine le cavalier F6 ça serait la fin
serait le match nul sans doute
tout à fait
alors est-ce que ça sort Sabina
c'est de
la position un peu difficile avec le fou
G2 qui va dominer la position puisqu'il
est ouvert
et bon elle est pas elle est loin d'être
foutue mais on rappelle qu'un demi point
suffit
à toute la team indienne un demi point
sur 4 échiquiers donc autant dire que
tu crois pas
non mais il y a que Francky qui croit
pour son mug mais je pense que c'est une
croyance intéressée il vise le mag
j'ai un petit peu un peu
j'aime pas les données
[Musique]
ouais donc en fait c'est la lune en fait
la lumière doit venir de cet échiquier
en fait en gros
si le fou ne bouge n'importe où il va
aller en D6 sans doute
c'est vrai tout ça
il est parti à la pêche après
elle a deux minutes de plus
elle est mieux c'est l'âge de toute
façon
puis elle a dû prendre un petit coup sur
le casque mine de rien parce que elle
vient de prendre trois bulles
c'était en plus à sens unique elle a pas
beaucoup vibré même si elle était pas
favorite je pense Laurent c'est ça nous
entends tous de prendre trois bulles
d'affilée même à cette cadence là bien
sûr
évidemment la confiance c'est pas le
mieux voilà elle a 6 minutes contre 3
une position qu'on pourrait qualifier de
poubelles parce que les pièces sont très
très bien placées avec les Blancs donc
ça sent pas regarde les deux cavaliers
salut corbeau c'est merci ciel bleu qui
nous dit que Jul est gagnant je peux
adopte super
à 2350 aujourd'hui donc c'est vrai faut
se méfier mais c'est quand même des
appareils très très abordables
exactement pour les joueurs avec la
qualité de Jules Maxime ou Étienne
mais faut faire donc il y a 23 places
qualificatif pour la Coupe du Monde qui
arrivera au mois de juillet faut faire
faut faire plus 4 c'est à dire 4
victoires sans défaite en gros avec un
bon départage attention des partages
tous les joueurs à plus 4 sur mon
expérience sur un pas qualifié c'est à
dire qu'il faut faire un très bon début
de tournoi c'est important et d'ailleurs
toi Laurence ça te ça te dit pas ce
genre de compète parce que bon on
comprend tu nous as dit que tu étais
moins joueur qu'avant mais ce genre de
compète ça pourrait être un bon petit
challenge peut-être non ouais j'ai
failli j'ai beaucoup hésité mais il se
trouve que j'ai un j'ai un bouquin à
écrire
ah oui mais bon on sort on sait ce que
ça va faire
deux mois
là ça faisait encore un break de deux
semaines et tu sais commencer c'est pas
un break de deux semaines pour jouer
parce que moi je suis je suis
compétiteur donc je vais pouvoir me
préparer
ça me fait un break de trois semaines
puis après en revenant je vais être
fatigué bon bref ça fait un break de moi
quoi donc ça commence à faire un coup de
break et donc j'ai un peu j'ai hésité
j'ai hésité puis au final je me suis dit
que c'était pas raisonnable tout ça et
donc
et donc j'y suis pas allé mais l'année
prochaine je reviens si mon livre est
fini
il est déjà annoncé le chemin d'Europe
c'est selon mon expérience vaut mieux
jouer tu sais il y a deux ans pour se
qualifier vaut mieux jouer le premier en
fait parce que les gens sont un peu
comme moi il s'énervent tous à la
dernière minute et donc ils sont pas
qualifiés ils vont tous à la deuxième
année la première année c'est plus
tranquille
donc si j'avais dû jouer j'aurais joué
l'année dernière
plus que cette année mais ouais non je
pense que j'en referai
je crois qu'il y a pas de 27 cette année
mais il y a une densité de très fort
joueur à plus de 2006 qui est
ultra impressionnante tout à fait c'est
souvent comme ça
tiens 26,98 c'est quoi ça glissant je
sais plus qui est tête d'affiche
c'est pas impossible de se prendre un
petit foie F3 à un moment pour vraiment
le cavalier A6 alors vous avez quand
même une masterclass là de Sabina Foisor
avec les cavaliers au bord voilà
Laurent mais c'est vrai que
malheureusement je suis forcé de
constater
alors cavalier prend jouer après
Valentina gounina Sabina
en difficulté en tout cas là c'est dur
on reste on reste sur cette partie
on pourrait faire un petit tour de ça ça
fait longtemps qu'on a pas venu se nique
contre adiban
alors un petit tour des stades pour voir
si l'exploit est possible merci ciel
bleu mais ça c'est déjà fait les
antisysaines
alors les blancs contre adibam
ouais bon
et non
quand même mais les Noirs ont gardé les
bonnes pièces pour contrebalancer le
pion de moins Laurent
apparemment mais bon ok c'est plus
agréable à jouer côté blanc peut-être ça
pour venir là
ok pourquoi pas on peut y croire on peut
y croire allez on y croit
on y croit
moi je te le dis on y croit non en fait
la colonne regardez comme c'est
intelligent à cette poussée il a bien
stabiliser la position et puis balance
sous ses pions on a le droit pour
déstabiliser le cavalier ce qui tient
bien la pose
tout à fait et là on va pouvoir
travailler ouais il est bien il est bien
Google
bon travail c'est la petite séquence que
tu peux nous montrer les 10 15 derniers
coups Laurent pour voir la petite
séquence d'amélioration qui est qu'il a
réalisé il a poussé gentiment ouais il a
très très bien joué un gros cache très
très sympa regardez il a réussi à
pousser ses pions devant son roi parce
que il ne pourra pas gagner que sur ce
statu Colas les pièces noires sont un
petit peu enfermées donc il faut
travailler la position et amener
un petit peu de jeu sur les ailes en
plus de sa domination centrale pour
faire la différence c'est une pénis très
bien
Google ça c'est sûr salut
Arpa des lots est-ce qu'il y a un autre
match mais on va pas le ouais il y a
notre match mais c'est les matchs des
derniers il sera commenté sur la chaîne
anglaise donc n'hésitez pas à aller chez
nos chez nos frères le Chess.com sur la
chaîne anglaise
et ils vont suivre ça évidemment et
mgd1 non ça a pas été ça a pas été
résolu mais c'est Mumbai a priori oui
c'est ça
priori
je sais pas pour un prochain point
avec la case F4 et du coup ça lui laisse
un petit contrôle
ça reste léger
je vais faire ça
ok intéressant
et est-ce que
il nous reste
ça y est il est mal il est mal gauche
il est très mal oui
il est pas là en plus
ouais alors alors tu sais sur quoi ça se
joue Google très bien
you très bien
Hady
il faut l'exploit de Sabina on va rester
chez Sabina parce que là c'est là où ça
se joue et
en tout cas
elle a des pions j'ai
laffaiblissement en tout cas et énorme
côté côté du roi
donc on a une minute contre trois
alors pas bien il faut une gaffe
pas 50 solutions
[Musique]
nous l'a montré c'est le problème
principal avec la faiblesse du roi ça
fait deux problèmes à gérer allez
cavaliers C7 il y a toujours la tourment
en l'air donc on n'a pas le temps de
faire d'un F4
c'est pas bien joué de la F4
on a dit on a pas le temps
jouer
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce coup encore
elle est inspirée en plus elle est très
lente Sabina pense pareil
des joueurs très forts donc c'est elle
se bat au moins les courageuses mais
mais c'est dur ouais ciel bleu on est
d'accord roi H2 ça rigole pas
elle laisse rien au hasard attention
pas une miette de contre jeux avec
harika et elle se jouait finalement elle
voit qu'elle est pas en confiance
qu'elle a un peu lente du coup bah elle
va peut-être jouer la finale avec tout
recettes qui rentre c'est ça bon elle
veut faire tourner deux évidemment tout
recettes attaque F7 attaque B7 on est
obligé de prendre B2 pour essayer de
créer une course non non non non non
maintenant on a plus aucune chance de
gagner
on peut me faire
s
complètement dominé c'est la cata
ça va se terminer ce match va se
terminer sur cette partie comme prévu
hein
c'est vrai que c'était chaud j'ai sauvé
la vaisselle
on va sauver les mugs le mug
démonstration
même en cette cadence très rapide 10 + 2
c'est vraiment montrer dans tous les
écoles avec cette domination centrale
je travaille à l'endroit on pousse
devant son domine tous les chéquiers et
regardez-moi ça Rica aussi très pro elle
va encaisser ce pion d'abord et ensuite
celui-là d'abord faut aussi peut-être
gagner pour un Rica
très très forte grosse performance de
Rica aujourd'hui
propre très propre dur dur pour Sabina
qui a le mérite d'être là parce que
c'est vraiment pas facile même si elle
est déçue
qui est si c'est pas triste et on a
Christopher you on va voir quand même la
fin de la partie de Christopher you et
bien qui va certainement l'emporter et
faire un tout petit peu retourné quand
même
c'était beaucoup plus simple tout à
l'heure et là le pion il peut jouer pour
dame des 6 et 6 peut-être
le pion très avancé
tu as aussi mais bon
A4 oula non il a voulu jouer trop passif
bien jouer en protège F7 et comme ça on
peut s'en donner à cœur jouer avec sa
dame encaisser les pions il aurait dû
essayer de pousser jusqu'au C7 je sais
pas il a pas trouvé le contre jeu dans
le manuel de final là c'est bizarre pour
le joueur indien croisé on se met sur
des échecs
surtout il a pas poussé en C7 le pion on
serait un contre-pouvoir puisque tu
aimes bien le mot Laurent intéressant
et là on l'a pas
et on a eu le spoiler le spoiler c'est
que commencer attendez Christopher you a
gagné cette partie et oui dans ma vie
mais bon le suspense c'était
tué depuis
quasiment le deuxième le deuxième 7 en
vrai ce 300 et demi a fait très très mal
en fait tu redis après coup ce que j'ai
dit tu nous as fait croire Laurent qui
avait un suspense incroyable c'est ça
oui merci à toi merci à toi pour le
suspense ça le temps Laurent
que tu as maintenu que c'est plus facile
tu vois de faire un bilan quand le match
est terminé
j'aime beaucoup plus simple je trouve
exactement donc on va faire un petit un
petit point classement parce que je sais
que tu les aimes mes petits points
classement mais oui ça fait toujours
plaisir le petit point classement Indian
yogi c'est Gotham Knight qualifié
ensuite on a pas mal d'équipes avec deux
victoires sur trois matchs ça veut dire
qu'ils auront besoin qu'une d'une
victoire supplémentaire pour se
qualifier donc on a l'échange Tiger et
les litofest Wizards les Norway gnoms
les chess vois avec manus scarsen et
Croatie les tombeur de Blitz l'équipe
française et on a la team mg mg
qui va se joindre à ce groupe tandis que
Blitz c'est dans le un peu alors pas
éliminé ça c'est sûr mais favorable
ballotage défavorable il faudra gagner
les deux prochains matchs donc déjà la
semaine prochaine victoire impérative
pour l'équipe de Blitz on sait pas
contre qui joue les appareils vont être
fait à la fin de cette ronde il reste
encore un match qu'on va pas suivre
parce qu'on ne l'a pas demandé entre
voiture entre berline Beers et
Saint-Louis et malheur vaincu le vaincu
est éliminé tandis que le vainqueur
devra gagner encore les deux prochains
matchs pour espérer se qualifier pour la
phase élimination directe qui regroupera
les 8 meilleurs équipes
après je sais pas exactement quoi ça
marche pour les enfants les équipes
indiennes se déroulent très bien à
Laurent
voilà
il y a deux c'est ça
une déjà qualifiées et une en ballotage
très favorable qui est perdu son premier
match contre Blitz c'était un appareil
mort difficile pour Blitz mais depuis
mais leur chemin ce sont en tout cas
leur couple ce sont complètement
inversés
bah écoute je te remercie mon cher
Laurent comme d'habitude de ce stream
d'avant week-end et je me dis est-ce que
tu sais alors tiens alors une petite
question technique pour finir ce stream
en beauté vas-y est-ce que tu sais faire
des raids via le compte chasse.com
est-ce que tu as la possibilité de le
faire parce que je vois que notre ami au
chat est en plein stream et je suis sûr
que tu l'aiderais bien mais est-ce que
tu as la possibilité de mettre le raid
en place et là je te pose peut-être une
colle technique
j'ai pas les
je crois que c'est que chaises comme fr
qui peut non mais c'est sûr en tout cas
je peux pas
donner les clés du camion encore
techniquement il est il est là sinon je
sais le faire
il y a pas de problème il est là Nathan
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire il dort tout à
l'heure tout à l'heure il était pas il
était pas jeune notre ami Nathan
à mon avis tu as vu ce qui t'a vu les
questions
je suis assez d'accord là j'ai pas
toujours été d'accord avec tes remarques
Laurent mais alors là je suis
complètement peut-être que Robin side il
sait faire ça aussi
alors moi je crois que j'ai pas la
possibilité de le faire pour être très
honnête
[Musique]
d'oral avec un autre technique
le raid oral voilà c'est pas mal admin
de base donc je sais pas comment on fait
ce truc bon bah il dorme tous ils sont
tous partis en week-end je peux te dire
ils sont peut-être à l'apéro ensemble en
fait ouais c'est très probable en tout
cas nous on va en faire demain mon cher
Kévin ne bois pas trop ce weekend soit
soit raisonnable
de badiste j'essaie j'essaie tous les
weekends je me le dis que j'ai ma
carrière de baliste à relancer et du
coup c'est pas facile le rendre donc je
fais des efforts mais c'est dur hein tu
sais et c'est slash red oui mais alors
slashred avec quoi de de Doom j'ai
jamais fait de raid à personne moi
[Musique]
je sais je sais que c'est très à la mode
sur twitch mais nous on utilisait plutôt
YouTube et on était pas sur twitch
souvent ça me fait ça me fait plaisir
cette fin de stream
à personne on m'en a fait beaucoup mais
moi j'ai jamais ok bon on va se mettre
au point là-dessus Laurent et moi je
peux pas t'aider parce que c'est celui
qui
met alors comment je peux faire sur je
fais ça comment en fait
[Musique]
pour pour se marrer tu sais non non il
essaie vraiment t'aider mais je suis pas
sûr qu'il puisse le faire Laurent mais
je sais pas en tout cas sur Obs je vois
pas comment faire non bon en tout cas
merci d'être créateurs merci infiniment
de nous avoir suivi un bon week-end à
tous et à toutes bon week-end à tous
merci à toi Laurence tu es vraiment très
sympa de le faire en ta compagnie et
alors attends j'essaye de faire le raid
du Plata
non pas de correspondance tu vois
non je peux pas le faire
j'ai des trucs recouest non je peux pas
le faire je suis désolé quand même ouais
merci ça servait à rien mais
me remercie quand même on est poli
ciao ciao bon weekend à tous des bisous
bon weekend